The Joe Rogan Experience.
Cast.
By.
Trevor Moore ladies and gentlemen Trevor walked in.
The first thing you said is I have one of these electronic cigarettes.
Do you mind if I take a hit off of it and just synchronicity it was just when
Jamie put together this thing.
This dude sent me that.
You could kind of lift weights with you didn't think you could fucking kill
somebody with this for sure.
Because it's like it's very heavy and there's all these sharp edges for the
folks at home that are not watching they're just listening.
This is so unnecessary.
It must weigh.
I would say of a pound maybe 2 2 pounds maybe you know like a briefcase.
Yeah.
How much would you say that weighs if you'd had a guess with a pound maybe.
Yeah more than that I would feel like yeah maybe two pound.
Yeah this is this is the heaviest one of these I've ever seen so fucking stupid.
And so you you you take it it's tobacco and you you know you press the button
the bottom has a button and you take it.
It's like it doesn't move possibly sucking on that thing.
It looks like garlic on exhaust for a very small car.
Yeah I mean it might as well have like if it's gonna be like that it might as
well have like a brass knuckles component so it could be like a self-defense
weapon.
Yeah like a key ring and you know like right try getting on a fucking plane.
I tried telling the people on the plane.
This is my Veep and the part of Veep culture and I like ve been sweeping this on
a plane a dude came up to me at M problem was talking to me he had one of those
well yours sounds cool.
Here's has a weird tone to it.
Yeah.
James made it sound like it's Vader's jet with Darth Vader whispering It's a
quiet Darth Vader.
This isn't really how much of a noise
play mine here
my latest is just the sound of breathing and then a giant puff of smoke.
Yours doesn't have as much smoke either.
Now I think my my coils are bad.
I've got to redo the coil coils.
Man.
What is.
You know it just started off with those little fake cigarette jammies.
Yeah.
Like those blue cigarettes.
Well I've been doing this since 2007.
You early adopter.
I know.
Like well if they if they find out that something's wrong with these I might
post like you know it takes like 20 years to actually figure out if something's
wrong with.
They go Hey whoa this is.
Stop everybody.
But when I started you had to get them from England.
Like yeah you'd order it.
My friend was a comic who was like You know I was smoking too much and he.
And he was like I just quit I started doing this stuff and you ordered from
England and they would send it in.
Even like vials of the nicotine liquid and they had all these big gloves that
would come with it and it would say they had this book that was like if you get
this on your hands and it absorbs in it can give you a heart attack.
What thought so.
Yeah.
I don't know if it was there just being like you know overcautious or whatever
but I was like You know every time I had a fill it I was in the bathroom like
making sure there's people in my house like alright if I get this on my hands
run me to the hospital or something so ridiculous.
That's so rude.
If you get it on your hand you'll die.
How potent could that be.
I don't know this stuff.
The guy said sent it to me sent me little bottles of this jazz.
This one says strawberry custard.
Yeah that's that's the thing now it's all like it's all fruit flavors like I do
the like pipe tobacco flavored minus strawberry custom.
This is a shitty handwriting.
You smoke it on a crunch berry crunch berry.
What does that say.
I say customer custard custard custard.
Yeah.
Shitty handwriting you strawberry custard.
You'd think we'd somewhat print that out.
This is like the beta.
This is the test.
Yeah I'm not sure about this.
Well I.
I like puffing on those little blue cigarettes like before I do standup because
I feel like it gives you like because I know nicotine is one of things I read in
Stephen King's book on writing is a great book.
You read it.
No it's Stephen King sort of like.
I think he calls it a memoir of the craft or something along those lines but
it's basically like talking all about his writing habits and his just as the
discipline of writing and you know what what you shouldn't shouldn't do and you
know how he started out writing and it's really really inspiring.
A great book but one of the things in the book he talks about cigarettes I need
to stop when he's quit smoking cigarettes.
It had a an adverse effect on his writing.
Yeah like you felt like a synapses didn't fire up as well.
And I thought that was really interesting.
So I started reading up on nicotine and nicotine the effect on the brain and
it's kind of a bit of a cognitive enhancer.
You know it's a bit of a stimulant.
It will yeah.
And it's one of the things like one of the good things about nicotine that they
don't really talk about that much is that they think that it staves off
Alzheimer's.
That's crazy.
It's like or there's some some sort of correlation between smoking and less
likely to get Alzheimer's maybe that cancer is doing battle with the Alzheimer's
cancer itself first.
So they go to war and then your body's revised it gives a battlefield or they
could.
Everyone dies before the age of you.
You usually get Alzheimer's.
Well have you heard of that.
They're doing things like they're shooting HIV and cancer and killing cancer.
Oh really.
Yeah there's all these weird bizarre studies that they're doing now are tests
where they're injecting like tumors and different you know really fucked up
parts your body with other diseases.
And the other diseases are attacking the fucked up part of your body.
But then do you have aids to worry about AIDS cancer and die.
I know that you live with AIDS.
Magic Johnson looks great.
It's not AIDS HIV HIV but does that does it.
Does that make you HIV positive.
You're putting so I think it's an inert form of HIV allegedly.
I don't know.
Some people don't know.
I mean if you're gonna die of cancer if you had a choice between like pancreatic
cancer or HIV take HIV all day right because they got that thing pretty nailed
down.
I have a friend who I've known for
maybe 20 years and he's been HIV positive for like most of that time and he's
great.
He's fine hey he's fine.
It's normal.
I mean you see him he's always laughing and nothing wrong with him.
Huh.
It's weird.
When was the turn for that.
Was it like oh it's it's like last 10 years right where all of a sudden it's not
as I'm not not to say it's not as big of a deal but like it's certainly less of
it's certainly slightly less of a death sentence.
You know I don't think it's a death sentence at all anymore.
I mean it's a testament to science you know.
Protease inhibitors and all these different things that they figured out how to
how to stunt the progress of HIV.
It's it's super controversial because there's been a lot of like weird
correlations between the crushing of the immune system like obviously it's an
agreement that HIV or most people are in agreement that HIV is or causes AIDS.
But there's a bunch of people that say well it's that maybe but there's also
this thing about partying like in the gay community especially there's rampant
drug abuse like and that for whatever reason people do want to factor that in
and there is this guy that I had on the podcast that I think had a faulty
connection and his is he's actually a biologist at the University of Berkeley
University California Berkeley it seems Peter Duisburg and he's super
controversial because he doesn't believe that HIV causes AIDS.
He thinks that AIDS is you know AIDS being immune deficiency syndrome acquired
immune acquired immune deficiency syndrome and he believes that it is directly
correlated with partying directly correlated with use of crystal meth with
poppers AML nitrate crushing the immune system and no other scientist support
him no credible scientist support us.
We had him on the podcast he was pretty convinced convincing to an idiot like me
zero medical biologicals studying.
But the more I talk to people who understand no one wanted to debate him which
is really interesting.
But I think it's kind of like debating a Holocaust denier.
It's a controversial Yeah.
You don't want to you know you want to give him credit you know.
So he's like he's got tenure at University California Berkeley but he can't get
any funding anymore.
No I don't have anything to do with them.
Apparently he's done tremendous work with with cancer but because of this whole
HIV AIDS connection thing he's kind of blackballed.
And I was in touch with a lot of scientists after this was over was really
interesting because people got really upset with that podcast with him on that
podcast and then me giving him a platform and I'm like Look man the guy was in
Spin magazine.
He's you know he's been he's written a bunch of articles about this.
I just wanted to hear what he had to say about it.
Yeah.
So having him on was pretty interesting but I think it's I don't think he's
right but I think he has a point in that it's got to have an adverse effect on
your body.
And gay people like to party.
I mean it's just a fact you know and Crystal Matthews and Emile nitrate use it
like those are devastating to your immune system.
So if you've already got something going on you are more susceptible.
Yes.
Yeah.
But that doesn't it doesn't get factored in very often and I think that's where
Duisburg because he kind of brings that up.
I think you know it kind of gives the whole thing is a little bit cloudy because
of that and because it doesn't get factored in but that shit's super super bad
for your body HIV.
No.
Hardy partying all that you know the poppers and crystal meth and all that shit.
It's just like you know gay people don't have kids.
They do have kids.
It's rare you know that just they're out there having a good fucking time just
doing math banging each other getting sick.
I I always I love like hanging on this a couple of conspiracy theory boards just
as I'm like fascinated by it like I just it's only my fear of things in the
world are this conspiracy theories like even ones I don't believe in.
I just love them like my favorite one ever is.
There's a whole bunch of people out there who actually think that Lady Gaga is
JonBenet Ramsey.
Oh good Lord.
Yeah I like that real yeah.
There's a whole bunch people that think that.
And so it's like those things that put up the pictures where they show like the.
I like the eyes are the same.
You know distance across and like that kind of.
But there's one there's a whole group of people who don't think Magic Johnson
ever had HIV.
They think that it was a kind of almost a PR campaign to get awareness out.
Really.
Yeah.
I don't I don't believe that.
But it's like it's a fascinating conspiracy theory where people are just like it
was a huge problem.
It was a problem in like inner cities.
And he was the biggest guy at the time he was kind of like this huge role model
and for somebody like him to come out and say I have HIV.
Then like it could be like a big kind of get awareness out kind of thing that's
like oh he conspired.
That's what that's.
I mean why would he do that.
Yeah but it's a vague it's a conspiracy theory but ridiculous.
Well he is one of the few guys that was reportedly heterosexual that got it.
You know like did you ever see Sam Kennison a bit Sam Kinison.
You hear the crackle ladies and gentlemen only.
I'm going to support solidarity.
Well yeah synopsis.
What the fuck was I saying.
This stuff the same kinds of Sam Kennison Sam Kinison had a bit about it you
know.
Well you know because he had he made fun of AIDS and they say Sam you know he's
a communicable disease heterosexual diabetic.
Those name on line one fucking guy.
It's not our dance you know but really it's not by many and there's very few me
when I was a kid and I heard about Magic Johnson getting HIV.
I remember thinking Oh my God everyone's gonna have AIDS and like maybe a year
or two later I got health insurance and I had to get an AIDS test and I was
fucking terrified just thinking of all the drunken poor choices with no condom
and oh my goodness it's gonna happen I have AIDS I'm only twenty five of AIDS
shit and then I didn't have AIDS and so super psyched but then I started looking
into it.
It's like it's almost like very very few heterosexual people that aren't
intravenous drug users.
Users yeah they get AIDS.
Yeah I mean I mean I remember it like when I was a kid it was there they treated
it like it was you know you have sex without a condom once you're gonna get it
it's going to happen.
It's just it's an inevitable you know kind of thing.
And now I think now they're kind of backing off that a little bit where it's
like well it's actually not.
I think it's way more easy for a woman because obviously the woman takes sperm
into her body and her body absorbs it or gay men because you're a gay man even.
You're taking it in your ass and you're not supposed to have come in your ass.
What's up.
It's on.
I'm just sitting it down.
You made it.
Oh just this stupid fucking thing is so heavy.
There's a safety on it.
Mine has a safety on the bottom.
There's no safety on this piece of shit that's been Oh my God it's so hot.
Oh my God if I if I licked that right now if I tried to suck on it it would
probably burn.
I came in said it.
I got to set it down sideways.
You can't set this for people at home at eliciting which is most people see it.
You do it right.
Yeah.
The top of it is super hot.
See there's a safety right here so you spin that down.
Oh no I'm taking it to safety.
That's a battery.
Well mine has a year is better.
Mine has a thing like that.
So you're doing it again.
Smoke started coming out of
this thing.
I'll try to describe it.
You know what it looks like.
It looks like a spaceship in a shitty 1990s sci fi movie.
That's what it looks like.
That could be some sort of a spaceship.
Like you know.
Yeah it's fucking horrible.
AIDS.
Where were we.
It's conspiracy theories.
AIDS.
Yeah.
I don't know what it was.
I know what we're talking about but the JonBenet thing is interesting.
When I was living in Colorado I actually looked at her house the house that she
was killed in.
I didn't look at it in person but it was for sale and I was like wow what a
beautiful house.
I was pretty reasonable for what it is.
And they actually changed the street name.
They changed the street name or changed the address.
Right.
One of those.
And like to try to hide the fact that it was the house where JonBenet died.
But they have to disclose it.
Don't they do have to disclose it.
And that's the problem.
They can't fucking sell it.
Yeah.
Who's gonna buy that.
It's a beautiful house.
It's really nice and it's a nice area of Boulder but nobody wants I fucking.
No.
Ten dollars.
Len Bias.
I'd buy for ten bucks.
Would you live in.
Would you say behaves.
For a show for a TV show like a go show fucked up man.
That whole stories.
Oh look I think I think that whole child pageant thing is one of the most fucked
up things when you see little kids with high heels and makeup on.
Yeah.
Dressed up like you know they're trying to get laid.
So Cary is like you know the worst parenting.
It's weird man.
We were in Dallas and we were doing the improv in the hotel that we were staying
at was the exact same hotel where they were having one of these pageants.
And we.
It was me and I think Duncan and Joey and we were walking around the hotel
going.
What the fuck is this.
Yeah it was all little tiny kids like 5 like I have a I have a 4 year old and I
have a 6 year old so they were like my kid's age but they were wearing high
heels where they could barely walk and they were fully dolled up.
I mean eyelashes full makeup war paint.
Yeah.
Oh teased up Texas style hair like little dresses.
I mean it was disgusting.
It was disturbing.
Was really really weird.
Just the fact that just putting them into like a judging scenario at that age.
Yeah.
You know kind of like well you weren't the best kid.
You know you didn't you know everyone you got up in front of everyone but they
like this other kid better than you.
So yeah psychologically rattled that around in your brain for your whole life.
My daughter was playing softball or soccer rather for a while and her nickname
was Bruiser.
My youngest one is like super aggressive.
She's crazy but she's really like she's a sweetie.
But when it comes to thinks she's like she loves like Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and she's a Superman lunchbox probably a lesbian but I love her to death
but she's she's really athletic and so she's only four.
And so they had her in soccer and she's just scoring goals like crazy.
The game starts.
Boom she scores the first goal.
She runs the ball boom scores a second goal.
I mean she's like a little animal and then the other team scored and she's start
crying because you're the team was cheer and she started crying like that.
The family on the other side with the families were cheering and then she's like
I don't want to play anymore.
And the coaches like you got to go back out there and play I'm like you don't
have to play I go it's just stupid it's a ball going it's the net I go if you're
not enjoying it don't do it yeah I go but you shouldn't worry about the other
team.
It's like scoring but I knew that she couldn't kind of internalize that.
So I said this is no big deal I don't want to make it a big deal because I think
that sports a lot of times parents they fuck their kids up because they make
like winning and losing this like huge deal or playing you got to get out there
you got to look and play Yeah figure that out when you're older you know when
you're four you should be having fun you know and that's I mean the coaches like
sitting down with they're trying to psych her out and the coaches dummy shit.
So when she's sitting down she's giving her the dumb psychology as I go but well
stop stop stop stop stop don't teach my kid.
Come here honey.
Sorry.
It's some big deal.
Yeah.
She's like you've gotta go out there and you got to just go out there and you
get that score back.
What have they scored.
If you feel bad you've got to go.
None of them did it.
Get out of here.
No you don't.
Yes.
Have fun.
Relax.
Like this is just supposed to be fun.
So the idea that you could take someone that age and then judge them on their
looks.
That's fucking insane.
And you know they have like a talent portion where they have they saying and do
little dances in their high heels and you know what the fuck man likes it so on
who is the pedophile that invented this first guy who is like I have an idea for
a thing to do.
I think it's people that are just living through their kids man.
Yeah you see that a lot with with sports.
You know you really see that a lot with you know people that like it's usually
fathers with their sons like fathers like.
Like really fucked their kids up because they're like super some guys you know
obviously some guys like fucked our kids up to they're super super super
invested in their kid being successful like I've seen kids not do well at
certain sports and seen their fathers yelling at them.
You're talking like 10 year old kids like God damn and like you're to the only
way these kids are really good at something is if he's rewarded for his hard
work.
And then if he gets a sort of an understanding of what is healthy and was not
healthy about competition.
Yeah what's definitely not healthy is you you putting everything on the line for
this kid like it's everything like your love your love is invested in this kid
knocking a ball into a net.
This is fucking preposterous and it's just so goofy.
Dads just see that Tiger Woods money and think that's what it is.
I mean I don't know.
I mean it's it's probably it's probably a column a which is them trying to you
know redo their you know what they wish they had done.
Yeah.
Then there's also like my kid could be the greatest quarterback my kid could be
you know.
Yeah I think that could be in the future they might be looking at it that way.
We're gonna get you on that doesn't make that noise.
Oh sorry I won't do it.
I do it's okay.
I just push the microphone.
But the audience is probably going.
People that have headphones on is that the headphones are the real issue.
Sorry.
Because sometimes we have these fight companion podcasts where we have a bunch
of guys in here and watch fights and people start eating snacks and they're
eating right into the microphone and if you listening if you have headphones on
it's fucking maddening but it's hard you know you're drinking and smoking pot
and people forget and they start chewing.
Anyway JonBenet Ramsey not not a good place to buy a house.
Age just done JonBenet Ramsey is done we cover those super duper important
things conspiracy there's one that thinks they think that Bill Hicks and Alex
Jones are the same person I've seen that.
Yeah.
Trust me I've met both of them they're different humans.
Fucking christ people are so crazy.
Could you imagine.
Like why why would you do that.
I want to be the buddy ever done that.
Has anybody ever faked their own death.
Tupac
Andy Kaufman.
Andy Kaufman Tupac live on an island somewhere.
All right.
What a boring fucking life waiting to die of old age.
Yeah but that's also maybe one of the best sitcoms ever.
Tupac and Andy Kaufman alone on an island somewhere like an odd couple.
How long before gay shit starts happening.
How many months and
it's got to be early right away.
Yeah right.
Fuck it we're here.
Let's be honest no one's rescuing us.
I don't know of anyone that's ever fake their own death successfully.
I know some people have tried.
There was a guy that I remember it was some business guy who apparently got
busted swindling or something like that.
He faked his own death.
They caught him a few years later.
Yeah.
And then that guy that's in the movie The Jinx the show The Jinx.
Yeah that guy that what is his name Robert Durst Robert Durst.
Yeah he had a guy that they know but he disappeared and pretended he was a woman
right.
He pretended he was a mute woman like to put on a wig and dressed like a woman.
And then as a mute woman murdered another guy and took off.
And that's like.
Whitey Bulger did it for a while.
That's where he disappeared but didn't fake his own death.
No.
Yeah I heard.
I don't know if this is true.
I heard and I don't I don't remember where I heard it so this could just be
nonsense.
But that was his plan was to do it like when he was gonna get old and die was
gonna go out into the desert dig a hole and just basically you know kill himself
in the hole so they never find him.
Bolger Yeah.
I don't know that's true or not.
I heard that you got to kill yourself where animals would eat you right.
That's the move.
What you should do if anybody wants to kill themselves and not be found go to
Alberta go to Alberta Canada go to where the bears are because there's sections
of Alberta Canada that are literally infested with black bears.
You and they have a few Grizzlies up there as well but I've never seen more
bears in one place in my life like in one day you'll see 16 bears like no shit.
Yeah fucking big bear seven foot bears and just blow your brains out every
summer.
Honey.
Yeah.
Because the bears eat honey and Nellie you know they'll have you'll be gone.
They'll eat your bones clean everything they'll eat every every single piece of
who you are they'll shit out your teeth and that's that'll be a wrap.
Nobody will find you good.
It's a good life or the ocean.
The oceans are the best.
Yeah.
They just are not going to find you.
And you go out far enough and just jump just jump out.
Yeah.
Just start breathing.
You'll fucking sink to the bottom.
The odds of your body making it all the way to shore.
Not so good.
Yeah.
I mean think about how goddamn big the ocean is.
Who's gonna find you.
Nobody.
That's probably good move the oceans by better than the bear move but it's more
peaceful serene all up.
It's terrifying the oceans peaceful in the day at nighttime it's fucking
horrific.
Yeah I was out sailing once in New York and we went out like a little far and
then it got dark and we were trying to come back and it was awful and the waves
got bigger and it was actually like a sailboat.
So like really kind of you know with the old like wheel and everything and
actually like feeling like the strength of the waves trying to get back and it
was really fucking terrifying.
Like trying to get back to New York.
That's a crazy way to die man.
Your boat tips over.
Know I'm trying to scramble and hope the boat stays afloat sideways and the
water's cold.
Yeah.
Oh ho ho ho ho ho ho ho.
I.
My kitchen was getting fixed.
There's shit wrong with my kitchen.
So we decided to rent.
We say oh well you know we'll do we'll rent a house on the water you know rent a
house on the beach for a couple of months.
And I got barbecued one night the first night we went there I got super duper
high.
And in the daytime it was beautiful like that like you look out the window where
you're eating breakfast and would just be ocean just like right there in the
ocean like wow so pretty.
But at nighttime.
That same view is horrifying because the sky is black and the is black and you
keep hearing lush.
And it's like it reveals itself to you like Oh you thought that this was like
your playground.
A beautiful thing.
There's a fucking monster that could swallow up the whole city and not even know
it.
Yeah like the ocean could just swallow Los Angeles one day with one burp slash
fart of the tectonic plates.
At least Malibu.
Oh yeah.
Malibu that would be done.
Santa Monica.
Done.
Yeah.
All that the promenade done just all those in the mall area with all the shops
and people playing songs you don't want to hear on the street a hundred foot
high waves just pouring in covering everything for 3 4 miles deep.
That's nothing that's happened a hundred thousand fuckin times in the course of
the earth.
And we just set up houses there.
Dig a man.
Boom boom boom fuckin posts have our way of all.
I was terrified in that house.
Man I barely stayed and I rented it for a few months and I'm gonna have to stay
in and my my other house my art my actually out my house with the fucked up
kitchen I was cooking on a hot plate.
I was like I feel more comfortable here.
Are you afraid of Sonam ese.
I'm afraid of everything.
Yeah I'm afraid of everything I'm afraid of asteroids wolves tsunamis are like
the one some birds one disaster for some reason I'm not afraid of.
Really.
Yeah.
I don't know why like my wife is terrified.
I think her biggest fear is tsunami.
She's smart.
And like whenever I see the tsunami I know this is just this is naive.
But whenever I look at tsunami footage and stuff I feel like I could.
I think I feel like I could get away like but I got so scared Snowmass Bill
caught my shirt.
You really think you get away.
You know it's I know it's stupid and I probably couldn't but I just have that
kind of thought right.
Like I feel like if I had to pick a natural disaster like I'm afraid of
earthquakes asteroids.
But like tsunamis I would never take that.
Imagine if you did.
If you if you were right and you like a suit tsunami came you survived like a
thousand people dead Trevor Moore.
How did you survive.
They're all pussies.
How do they not survive some fucking water just swim.
No I just think you know it.
I kind of always deep down felt like I could do it.
And you know it's turned out.
God told me I would be fine and the water is just water.
Just keep swimming and you're fine now.
If you ever could've been caught in an undertow.
Not a big one.
Like I go surfing and surfing like you know I've never been caught in like one
that was I've been caught in one and been like oh I'm an undertow you know.
But now not a bad one.
You know I've never been kind of bad when either but I got caught in one that
was enough that freaked me the fuck out.
I got caught in one.
Got to remember where it was but I remember like oh this is what that is.
Yeah.
And I'm you know pretty athletic.
I'm in pretty good shape but I was thinking man what if I was like a old lady or
you know a young kid.
Yeah yeah like this is not good.
Like the water just started pulling me back and that was pretty wrap and I was
like oh fuck this I started starts.
You've got to swim sideways.
Yeah lateral.
Yeah yeah.
Towards the shore.
Greg Fitzsimmons how to rescue someone.
He was on vacation with his family and some woman got caught in the undertow and
she was screaming and she was getting pulled out and he looked around and there
was no lifeguard.
There was no nothing.
And she was just getting pulled.
And so he was having his fucking wife and his kids yelling HOLY SHIT.
OK here we go.
And he just jumped out there and you know you've got to like know how to hold on
to people when you're saving them.
He denies they're panicking and they're just trying to get to higher ground on
top of the hour pull you with them they'll pull you with them and she she did
not know how to do that.
And so like you know he barely made it well barely made it and saved this this
woman.
But that moment when you you have to make that decision do I risk my life to try
to save some person because it might be get to a point where like Oh my God I'm
gonna have to punch this chick in the face and swim by myself because she's
gonna drag me under Right like there's those weird Mom that actually happened to
people when they're trying to save someone they realize I'm going to die too
because this person is an idiot you know.
Aw yeah maybe not an idiot but they can't they're panic and they don't know how
to deal with stress.
Some people given that exact same circumstance just know how to stay calm and
they'll be fine and other people they just and they can breathe like you like
Breathe breathe I can't breathe and I'll fucking christ like I can't teach you
how to breathe here while we're both trying to swim for our lives.
Fuck I mean his wife and his kids were watching this whole thing happen and you
know he kind of figured out how to grab her and swim to the shore with her and
that's some terrifying shit.
Yeah that's good I mean like Yep people we were we were doing like river kind of
rafting not I mean just like kind of a..
Like you know kind of like lazy river kind of stuff up in Cape Cod once me and a
bunch of friends and this river comes out to the ocean and when it came out to
the ocean there was one of our friends who doesn't swim so I don't know why he
was with us but like he was on one of those inner tubes just kind of like did he
have a life raft on to.
No he was just kind of tubing but it was like a river.
It was a river.
And so it got to the ocean and it was the same kind of thing where it just this
river just shoot stuff you know shoots the water out into the ocean really far.
So he went all of a sudden way out and we're all we're all back on the beach
we're like oh.
Holy shit lake.
Chris can't swim.
Oh.
So we're like going in and we see that he's panicking and in his panic.
What he did was he jumped off of the raft.
Oh no because the raft was going out to ocean and he just wanted to get back to
the shore.
So he does not swim.
I know but in the panic in that moment like you know your brain doesn't really
make the right decisions.
So I had to get him but how he died.
No no no
no.
We had people that had a swim out and like I get him back.
Did you get the raft who.
I don't know I don't either.
The money man.
I don't remember what happened.
Maybe not.
Oh fucking Christ.
Oh my friend Remy.
Remy Warren.
He was on a river once he was right next to a river and some stuff.
Saad he talked about on the podcast for folks listening to this.
His.
His version is gonna be way better than mine.
But he saw some stuff floating down the river.
And then a guy face down body floating down the river.
And then he realized holy shit like this is like a capsized boat.
It's freezing cold water and then a woman hanging on for dear life screaming and
he said Holy shit.
Here we go.
He just jumped in the river and was freezing cold water and he realized like as
he was jumping he's like okay I'm probably gonna die because this you know you
get hypothermia really quickly.
Yeah those means essentially those rivers are there.
They're glaciers.
It's glaciers melting and they create this river and it's fucking freezing cold
water in the mountain and he's in this water and it's not warm out either.
It's cold out.
And so he just drove in and he's trying to save this woman and he got lucky.
They both got lucky and they figured out a way to grab a hold of something and
you know.
But he got a hold of her and then dragged it to shore.
But he was pretty convinced as he jumped in like Okay this is it for me.
Been a fun life a good way to die to try to save somebody else.
That's pretty much yeah.
It's pretty heroic.
But if she dies to you like damn I could have lived and just want to die.
Yeah
just start telling people Hey man don't don't raft.
Shit's dangerous as fuck.
Well all the ways to die.
You know that's a river rafting is this is a really terrifying one.
If you see like when people there was such a reality show I forget what reality
show was but it never went to air because as they were filming like one of the
first episodes someone they overturned their canoe and got trapped under a rock
like the canoe overturned and the the waves or the the current rather wedged
them under a rock and they drowned.
You didn't like the pilot and the pilot.
Yeah.
This is years back.
This was like right when Survivor was first taken off before the internet really
took hold as far as like social media and TMC type shit which they would just
have a field day with this.
Yeah but back then it was just you know they didn't really they hadn't figured
out how to use the Internet for trash yet.
You know but this this this person just got stuck and I remember thinking that
like okay that's not something I ever want to be a part of.
You know now we are stuck in a freezing cold river with insanely powerful
currents.
Yeah I don't I don't I don't.
I mean some people like I've done it once the river rafting kind of thing like
the white water kind of stuff like that.
It's just not fun to me like it's it's it's very bumpy.
It's scary.
There's potential death everywhere people love thrills man they love it.
Somebody was they love that rush that adrenaline rush just poof.
I don't know.
I hinted this guy I've ever done skydiving now.
Yeah.
Fuck that yeah cause I feel like if you if you do die sky diving
it's you know it's always sad when people die but it's like you know it's kind
of you don't get that.
I mean people be like Well yeah.
He jumped out of an airplane.
You know I've had friends or EMT guys that have found people you know after
Scott got into the surface they saw their bodies totally intact.
It's everything inside you know.
Yeah.
But everything inside like your bones are like pushed up through your torso and
just like and you're just a bag of broken bones and destroyed organs.
Yeah not good.
I read there's this article there Jamie has a look at his face.
There is this article where they interviewed people who had actually fallen out
of planes and lived.
OK.
There's like only a handful but they were trying to figure out how you how to do
it and the stories were crazy because there's this one guy who was an old guy
that they interviewed who I guess was in World War 2 and his plane just
exploded.
Well he before he had jumped out a thing and he fell and then they say that is
the way to do it is and it's not like full proof but like the people who have
survived they kind of try to hit a tree and
you try to hit a tree as close to the middle as possible but not the exact metal
because that'll impale you that you want to hit close to the trunk where the
branches are the thickest and you basically want to have all the branches break
your fall on the way down and you're gonna be fucked up when like you hit the
ground.
But the people who have lived a lot of them hit trees.
Wow.
I heard a guy who lived to hit a barn and apparently went through the roof and
into the hay and somehow another made it but he was fucked.
Yeah I mean it was bone broken back broken.
You know all fucked up legs broken but lived somehow or another.
Yeah my friend Brian his dad had worked with this guy and the guy was trying to
get him to skydive and then you know when they went to the office and the guy
wasn't there he's like what happened.
Where's where's Mike or whatever the fuck his name.
That was actually a woman and I found out that the skydiving didn't go so well
that weekend.
Holy shit.
Yeah yeah.
It's dead.
Yeah.
Skydiving.
I don't get that sports don't like that one.
Well you know my friend Steve vanilla said it best.
He said there's things that are fun that are fun while you're doing them but
they're not fun later.
And I think skydiving is one of those roller coasters or one of those as well.
They're fun while you're doing them but they're not fun later.
And then there's things that you do like crazy arduous hikes over mountains and
you get to the top and you is insanely beautiful view and like you earned that
view and you know you're camping it's freezing and you know you're you're
fucking huffing but when it's all over when you get together like weeks later
and talk about that trip like wow you have these amazing memories like it was
really cool.
Yeah but at the time it was kind of brutal and arduous.
Would you ever do Everest fuck that.
Yeah that's that's that's that's like what the suicide basically.
But you have to watch this new it's out right now.
Glad you brought this up.
There's a real sports with Bryant Gumbel that's out right now.
What is.
It's amazing.
And it's on the Sherpas those fucking guys who have to do all the work.
Yeah.
Because they had all these experienced climbers who had summited at Everest like
years and years ago and they were talking about what it used to be like you know
used to carry your own stuff.
You had a minimal amount things and now they have these companies that set it up
like these luxury tours where these Sherpas they carry like virtually anything
you want like whatever you want whatever you need.
So they have all these prepped meals.
They have these tents inside these tents.
They have you know gourmet food and cots and all this stuff.
And these Sherpas have to carry all this stuff.
And it was sort of highlighting how insanely dangerous it is.
You know like there's only you know a few hundreds sherpas and over the last
couple of years 25 of them have died in avalanches and ice falls and the path
that they take from base camp up through the mountains like within the first you
know hundred yards or so you're in dangerous territory where there's dead bodies
all along the trail that they they can't get them.
You know they good die on the mountain you stay on your part of the mountain for
that on there there's like I was there's pictures up of the bodies like long
line and there's one guy that just looks like he's like slumped over taking a
nap.
And that's what happened like he was he still in his like parka and everything
like that but he just kind of you know when you get up that high you get tired
so you're like I'm just gonna rest for a second and then you're there for the
next 100 200 years including the first guy to ever climb Everest is he.
You could see his body.
Yeah look at that guy.
That's the first guy.
That's one of them.
Look at that fucking that's so creepy man.
But the first guy to.
That's the guy right there on the lower left the lower left.
That's the first guy to ever climb Everest.
Holy shit.
Yeah see I feel like that's gonna suck all the fun out of no matter like how
great the view is when you're walking up through just corpses you know like it's
gotta suck a little bit of no one out of it looks like someone chewed on his ass
look he's got a hole in his ass like some birds came on fucking.
Yeah but it's he's white.
White frozen solid face planted Yes.
Terrifying.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that is the body of the first guy because that's an iconic
photo.
But there's more than one hundred more one hundred dead.
But how many hundred how many how many dead bodies Jamie finding out Mallory is
the guy's name that died first right.
Isn't that his name.
This is the first guy that ever tried it.
I believe so.
He was the first guy that ever did it and then he died on the way down.
Some poor bastard.
I'm just gonna wait for the virtual reality.
They'll put a camera up there and meet on goggles and go through it will mean
anything.
I mean enough but the feeling of that thing is you're you've experienced it like
you like.
As you'd walking every fiber you're being he's going what the fuck are you
doing.
You gotta get out of here man.
Right.
This is dangerous there's no air.
It's 18 degrees below zero.
You got a mile of walking more than 200 dead bodies.
Oh my God.
Some bodies even used as landmarks for other climbers.
Fucking christ what.
Jesus how many people have successfully done it.
A lot.
Oh that was the fucked up thing about this.
This real sports thing.
As this guy was doing it he was talking about how crowded the summit is now when
you go up there like you could barely stand because so many people have
summited.
There's so many people there with you and then they showed the video of him
doing it and all the people making on the way up and there was over 100 people
on their way up the mountain.
I mean it was insane it was like there was a line for Disneyland.
I'm not kidding.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Look at that.
Look at all those fucking people.
That's insane.
Look at the legality the line the upper right hand corner.
Look at the law.
Look at that fucking line.
Now you can only do it like there's like a one week a year or something right.
Or it since it's a small window isn't it like a month or two.
I'm not sure where the weather is OK to do it.
I'm not sure but they you know people die all the time doing it.
Yeah.
And so these companies have sort of capitalized as one of the things they were
highlighting of capitalize on two things one does desire of all these rich
douchebags to you know like I'm an adventurer I'm summit of Everest I conquered
business now I've conquered the highest mountain in the world.
People love saying things like that.
I've summited Everest too.
You know John I'm so much more impressive now.
But the Sherpas it was really really really really depressing because they a lot
of them come from this one town that's like you know halfway up the mountain and
the town has been essentially the same way you can even call it town.
It's like a village.
It's a day's walk to buy food.
They have to walk for a day and this family this mother and her son were just
mourning the death of her husband and the kids father and as he was a Sherpa
first day on the job first time doing it you know they needed money to try to
get out of this village and they make like 5000 dollars a year.
And that's the equivalent to like that I'll go for a year out there probably
like way more than anybody makes up there doesn't want to help.
Wait wait wait.
I mean so it's like a I'm sure it's like a pretty much.
That's the that's the town business like that's a Sherpa community.
Yeah.
Well also they're uniquely like genetically qualified for the jobs they're
living up there.
They live up there.
They're used to climbing all the time.
They're insanely fit because their bodies are used to like very low oxygen very
high altitude so they can do things that other people just it's like super
difficult for like a person like us that lives here in L.A.
You know we're at sea level to go up there we'd be like Fuck you.
You know it takes a long time for your body to adapt.
Yeah like I lived in Colorado for a while and we were living at eighty five
hundred feet above sea level which is like 3000 feet above Boulder.
And it was just going up stairs was rough.
Yeah.
These fucking people were like What.
Twenty thousand feet more even I think like the summit is something like twenty
nine thousand feet above sea level so it's like essentially like almost as high
as a jet like when a jet is flying over Vegas like crazy.
Yeah it's insane.
MAN There's no air.
And they do with tanks too.
That's the other thing they do with oxygen tanks pussies.
We did a show in Aspen.
Like at the Aspen Comedy Festival and there's just like you know there's a
sketch show running around other thing but I had to have an oxygen tank
backstage just because like from the amount of like running around like after
the first show is like I can't I can't breathe.
Yeah.
I can't imagine being up at Jet level.
I did Aspen.
I did the comedy festival the probably same year you were there.
You guys you we didn't have any Trevor eyes from the whitest kids you know very
very famous sketch troupe.
You probably seen a lot of our stuff online model sketches online but we were
doing the Aspen Comedy Festival.
I want to say like two thousand three or something like that was way back in the
day and those with I was with Lewis Black.
We're on the show together and they they they had oxygen waiting for him when he
got on stage like they have a tank right there a little mask like you're sucking
oxygen out of the ghetto you know cause Lewis does that.
Well I don't think he's going to get very did you know you got no air.
Yeah.
No fucking air up there.
Well I mean when we got there they were saying like if you if I was feeling
faint or anything like that we have oxygen for everybody.
I was like that's you know I'm not gonna need the policy.
And then like Yeah 24 hours then I was like where where's the oxygen tanks.
Well they sell it.
They sell like tubes you could bring with you like I like it looks like a can of
hairspray or something.
Shaving cream it's got to go look a little mask thing.
But up Yeah that's nothing though.
I mean that's that's nothing compared to the altitude that these people are at.
So this is the same kind of thing.
What I did is basically like going to the moon on a bike.
Yeah Aspen is a freaky town isn't it.
Yeah.
The sidewalks are heated.
Yeah that was weird.
Like so rich she asked money up there it's so stupid.
Well they have to bus everybody at Lake because there's a McDonald's there and
over there and everyone who works there.
Anyone who works in any of those shops has to be bussed in from like an hour
down the mountain.
Yes they work there.
I guess there's no no one who works there lives there.
No.
You could never afford it.
Yeah.
Do they even have apartments.
I mean they must have some right now.
I don't remember seeing any but I remember seeing some stupid fucking expensive
houses up there.
It's a weird like rich people paradise you know.
The stores like they have like a Nobu up there like super expensive sushi place
or how are you getting fish up here.
This is the same.
Nowhere near the fucking ocean.
Yeah like Aspen is pretty high up there as well.
Eight thousand feet right.
Something like that.
It seems like it it's a goofy airport too.
That's horrible.
You have to fly like straight up.
Sure.
Yeah.
This year we went.
They don't think planes were coming in because it was snowing and so are they.
They called it off or something like that.
Someone with my ear.
So then so then it was basically I had to drive up the thing and that was
terrifying cause then the roads like you know if there's nobody driving on the
road for like five minutes the road's gone.
Yeah you know covered with snow.
Yeah yeah we we landed in Denver and then they bust us up and it took hours.
Yeah and you go on these winding roads in a boat you don't even know his driver.
He might be crazy.
Yeah.
How'd you get this job.
Can't talk to you.
You're the guy driving like you that your life is on the line you're on
mountains and on the way up there's all these buses just on the side of the road
they're just been frozen there because you can't go get them like on the way to
the Aspen Comedy Festival.
They're just littered with frozen comedians and buses.
It was a goofy place to do comedy too because like the audiences they either had
to live in Aspen or they had also like fly in for it and then they kind of
realize somewhere on line Oh executives just sort of built this festival so they
could ski the ice party.
Yeah.
So like when I was up there I remember thinking like this is very different from
the Montreal Comedy Festival where the Montreal Comedy Festival it really did
seem like it was all about the shows.
The shows were like an afterthought in Aspen and so they just canceled it.
Like it doesn't exist anymore.
And then they brought it to Vegas for a while and they were like well this is
even worse.
And then there's no more festival.
Yeah I mean HBO does HBO even have a comedy fest.
I don't think they do.
I don't think they do either.
Which is a shame because actually I thought was a fun festival.
So right.
But yeah I think I enjoyed it.
I don't.
I ski now but back then I didn't ski.
So I just was there just kind of having fun go on.
This is a weird place to have a festival like why would you go festival.
And then I kind of like sort of piece it together like oh you fuckers just like
skiing.
Yeah see all the agents and everyone's what Sundance is.
Yeah yeah yeah.
That all the shit with them on their ski and shit like this is fucking bizarre
like you guys have like this is an afterthought.
Yeah that's that's Hollywood.
You know the skiing skiing terrifies me does it.
Yeah that's that's.
I put that up there.
Well I just I know you can hit a tree and then you know.
Well you know what the thing is man just don't go on like a super tough course
you know.
Yeah that's the thing about skiing.
Like if you're going gonna ski.
Like everybody wants to go like crazy skiing is fun for me when I'm in control
of it like you know they have like black courses and blue like blue is like
fairly easy right.
It's like was like bunny slopes.
Yeah I was like well blue is not Bunny Blue's pretty like I was in Park City
Utah this year.
And blue is not easy like blue blue gets weird like there's some spots were like
whoa this is and I think green is like maybe blue is harder than green and green
is harder than blue but whatever it is I got to the the one right before Black
and I was like Well this is kind of crazy you kind of figure it out you just
gotta take like steep turns left and right to try to regulate your speed yeah.
But while I was doing it there were some motherfuckers that were just experts
that were fall by it and by me just as people that are just speed demons they
just really know how to do it and if they fuck up oh you know some of those guys
are going they probably won't like 50 mile an hour sometime.
Yeah.
And so there's no room for error no.
Also I was with my kids and the freak males like what are some uncoordinated
dummy plows into one of my kids when they're trying to learn how to ski right.
That's that's a potential danger.
But when I was a kid the first time I ever went skiing like my I took the little
lessons you know that you take in your first time skiing and then we were there
for like a Christmas thing my family's there for like a week.
So like by the second or third day I'm like I want to try the Black Diamond kind
of thing.
And my dad was like Fine.
Like he was just kind of like Yeah he like you know we learn a lesson or
something like Yeah go for it.
So I took the lifts up to the thing and nobody said anything like it was
totally.
Everyone's like all right this kid's gonna eat shit.
And it took me hours to get down because I couldn't I couldn't you know stay up
for more than you know 50 yards at a time without just falling because it's just
that the slope the pitch was just so much that I just would just keep tumbling.
And like crying trying to walk down this black diamond thing what Peter likes
flying past me.
Oh God did he tell you Dad when you got to the bottom.
Yeah I was like I hate skiing.
Did he do it.
What did you learn a lesson you take that black diamond.
How about a double black diamond.
Pussy Yeah.
The moguls are kind of crazy.
We we're watching people doing on Black Diamond mogul which are for people who
don't know what skin is like.
It's like massive bumps like the people like the bumps which I I'm real
confused.
I didn't understand why they would like sic air.
Is that what it is.
I think I think it is a kind of you're trying to get air off of the bumps aren't
you.
I guess you kind of do.
I mean don't jump too high because you kind of go on back and forth.
But we were we were going over it in the lift and we were watching these people
just go left and right and just hopping up and bouncing and it's the the actual
ground gets like etched in like this criss cross cross hatching pattern from
people just going left and right and left and right.
Oh it is crazy fucking bombs like Man that is a whole lot of room for error
there.
Yeah.
If you don't know what you're doing and you that you just jumped in like you did
just a little too quick you're in the trees.
Yeah.
What's safer school skiing or snowboarding.
What's easier to do.
I don't know.
Can you go as fast on a snowboard as you can on skis.
I feel like you go faster on skis but I'm talking on my ass.
But you do go faster and go.
Like a hundred miles an hour rule not on a snowboard you go straight down like
the downhill alpine skiing and the Olympics go really fast yeah.
Now I can't get that snowboard Aubrey's friends with that guy.
Bodie Miller who's Olympic gold medalist I watched him in the Olympics because
they were you know the Olympics was happening when Aubry was over at my house we
watched it while it was going live and that mother fucker fly.
You know when you watch it like Olympic gold medalists going down these things
like the speed is just unfathomable.
Yeah like you get to think that at some point in time like if if you wipe out
like he just wiped out recently almost severed his leg like he hit something and
tore his he almost tore the meat off of his leg and this acts like it's pretty
severe might might even be like a career ending injury like I think he hit a
fence or something.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
Fuck I just hit snow.
But if that's as fast as it is going the snow is right.
I think it's a I think he hit a fence.
My friend Steve was on the U.S. ski team and he's had.
I would I want to be conservative when I say this but I think I'm wrong.
I think I'm under shooting.
He's had 28 knee surgeries.
He actually had his his knees resurfaced.
I'll show you a picture you want to freak out.
He doesn't have any cartilage on his knee anymore.
How old is he.
Steve's in his 50s.
I've known him since I was a kid.
You ever find this image.
It's gonna freak you out but I'll pull it up here.
I'm not fucking
What's up.
Oh yeah.
You looking up at the screen.
Yeah.
Let me.
The record is actually a hundred fifty six miles down.
Oh my God.
Average speed for you.
One hundred forty two one hundred is average.
Yeah.
I never want to be going on in 56 miles an hour.
Yeah you're smart.
OK.
Look at this image.
Pull this.
I'll give it to you.
I'm off my laptop.
That's my friend's knee.
Look at that.
Does the NSG have the medals.
Yeah.
So they put medal over the top of his knee.
That's got to feel terrible when it gets cold.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He would never complain about anything this guy's an animal.
He doesn't give a shit.
He's got fake meniscus.
You see that little white thing there.
That's an artificial piece of meniscus that is a pad in between the the ball and
socket.
Those caps of his knees where you know normally have cartilage cartilage is so
worn away that he has these.
It looks like they're chrome like steel steel caps that cover over the top of
the bone.
And then you know it just sort of rolls steel to steel and that's a knee
replacement he doesn't have that.
No he just has his knee research his knee replacement is like for people that
have like their ligaments destroy my mama knee replacement should both knees
done at the same time that they'd chop your legs off basically and then they put
robot knees in and then you basically can't walk for a couple months and then
Lord yeah fuck man.
And they give you a whole bunch of like it and send you home.
Yeah.
The amazing thing is the hips.
They saw the top off.
They give you a fake hip a they like it's attached to like a screw that go like
the sore the top here your femur off and this fake hip screws right in there and
then you just start walking around like you're walking around within hours
really surgery.
Yeah hip replacement.
Yeah.
A guy that was yeah.
There's the hip there's the fake hip.
Whichever if you hear that sound that's Travers sucking on his I didn't like
the look at that.
How they do it.
They they they literally saw the top of your bone off and put this fake thing in
there.
This fake ball and socket.
That looks cool.
I will get it from aspirin.
That's hilarious.
The picture that you pull up is from Aspen.
I mean how many people that are super rich blow their hips out from skiing all
the time.
Probably a lot or just get that done cosmetically kind of be like to be
beautiful yeah kind of cyborg I want to have better hips but you see the top
which shows how deep it goes into the femur.
Yeah the screw like up above that Jamie above into the right you see that.
Yeah.
There likely that that's what happens.
They they put that fuckin steel thing Graham Hancock had it and he came on the
podcast six weeks later he was walking around like nothing like I had no idea
you know he goes Well I had my hip replaced I said when he was six weeks ago you
get the fuck out of here.
He was walking around like there was nothing wrong.
Now how long.
And it was like with the knee stuff like it last like 20 years or something.
And so then you got to do it again like 20 years or so.
How long did it take you to recover where she could walk like a couple months.
I think because she did both at once.
Like most of times you do one and then and then you do another one later but
she's done both.
One she said fuck it let's just suffer one.
Yeah.
She's like a schoolteacher.
So she was like I got this summer open let me just get a book done out of the
way.
And my eyes.
Well what was wrong with her knees that she had to do that.
I think just the cartilage wore down like it wasn't an injury or anything it was
just kind of wear and tear.
That's one of the reasons why I don't trust certain doctors because there's
other ways to handle that.
First of all they're doing these stem cell injections now on people's knees
where they're regenerating cartilage.
You know obviously that's not an option.
Once they chop your fucking legs off and put a fake knee in.
Right.
But doctors love doing that.
They love doing surgery you know I had a back injury and I talked to a doctor
and he's like well I've gone for future discs you know there's no other way on
this.
We're gonna chop it out and now I'm fine.
I got I sought out a bunch of alternative methods and I did this thing called
Regina King is blood spinning procedure that reduces inflammation the last
stretching and yoga and a lot of strengthening.
It's fine now.
Yeah.
I want to listen to this asshole and I'll have my discs fused right now.
And what is I don't know that means like what was it like cut the soft part in
between the bones like your spinal column is a series of bones and in between
those bones or discs which is like sort of like a tough bag of like jelly and
that bag of jelly a lot of times gets herniated where it pokes out and because
of trauma it all starts sticking into the nerve and it causes pain.
That's where sciatic comes from.
You know that term like sciatica.
Yeah.
People go Oh I have a sciatic issue.
Well you know what that really means there really means you have a bulging disc
means you're bulging disc is poking into a very specific area of your spinal
column.
It's a specific area of your nerves that affects where your your leg is and so
it can cause atrophy in your leg.
Which I've I've had friends that have had that issue.
It can cause like some pretty severe lower back pain and leg pain.
It like through your butt down your hamstring all the way down like shooting
down your leg.
So what they want to do is cut that meat out that soft cushy part and then they
drop it down and screw the bones together.
So now you have one part of your spine that just doesn't move.
So you can't your brain doesn't articulate the same way.
Yeah.
Now they've developed the same guy that invented well not the same guy the same
in the same country other in Germany.
They they're they're doing things in Europe that they're just not doing in
America yet for whatever reason.
And one of the things they're doing is they're replacing the disks with
artificial disks that articulate they move around much like your actual the
actual stuff that's in between your bones do.
So instead of fusing it and having this one stiff rigid area which actually is
can be really problematic because it puts pressure additional mechanical
pressure on the above disk and the below disk.
So oftentimes people wonder having multiple disk fused and you get like one
stiff fuckin back and you're walking around like this and you are shorter like
it makes you shorter and makes you have all sorts of problems like mechanical
problems the way you're boss because your body's like going What the fuck is
going why are we built different now.
Yeah well how come I can't move my neck anymore.
Why is it all but it's really common.
People get it done all the time.
They fuse the disks and you don't always have to know there's there's other ways
around it.
But a lot of doctors just want to start cutting you just don't want to start
doing.
I mean there's very ethical doctors and there's some times where they have to do
it.
There's sometimes when you like you know you're really fucked up man.
We have to do surgery to open up your nerve pathway because your arms are
atrophying which is really common with people that have neck injuries there.
They'll have a one arm they like shrivels up like it's not getting any nerves.
The nerves aren't firing anymore because they're being impinged by this compare
this this disk is bulging disk scary scary shit.
No but doctors just want to fuck and cut you up man.
They make money doing it.
Yeah sure but the doctor arrested recently.
He was arrested because he was lying to patients and telling them they had
cancer and giving them chemotherapy for profit.
Well yeah that's a fuck man.
Yeah.
Intentionally misdiagnosing people and then giving them fucking chemotherapy.
How did they catch him.
I don't know.
Someone got a second.
A bunch of people got a second opinion kind of maybe right.
Yeah.
Like what can't what.
You love cancer.
You're not even fat it doesn't look like that's gonna be a weird turn when
you're a doctor and you're just like you know you're like I'm going to be a bad
doctor right.
You know because you can't.
I mean you have to know you're a bad doctor at that point you're like I'm a bad
guy you know.
Yeah.
Some people have a way of dancing around reality.
You know there's a book called Dead doctors don't lie.
This guy doctor Joel Wallach who's so kind of an eccentric character.
And lastly the premise of a lot of what his book is about is about how few
doctors really understand nutrition and the understanding the impact of
nutrition on the body and mineral deficiencies that people have that you would
treat in like livestock like and in animals.
A lot of times when the animals develop issues they change the diet and we give
them minerals and that they don't do that with people.
And he found that particularly fascinating because I think he started out as a
veterinarian.
And one of things he was talking about is how many doctors abuse drugs because
they can get them like it's really easy for doctors to get drugs.
And you know he details like this one story of this guy who was in the middle of
an operation stepped away and shot cocaine into his body and had a fucking heart
attack and died.
So he was in like a storage room dead while this person was cut open in the
middle of surgery and they had to try to go look for him and they found him.
But you would think that you know when you're a doctor you have access to you
know prescriptions and you can get a hold of some medicine.
And I'm sure it's probably more tightly regulated today than it was in years
past.
Yeah I mean I'd heard that about dentists or dentists.
You know a lot about the dentists have the highest rate of depression for any
occupation the highest amount of suicide for any occupation.
Yeah.
And a lot of people think that it's because people hate going to the dentist
like it's kind of a universal nobody wants to go to dentists.
They kind of put it off like that they only go when they have to think they're
in pain.
So every single person that a dentist sees every day of their professional life
is people who are having the worst day of their year and they're dreading it.
So there's this energy of everyone coming in and being like I'm not happy to see
you I'm stressed out.
And that kind of wears on these dentists.
So they have the highest suicide rate and and I've I've heard that because of
that there's a lot of abuse of because they have the drugs too but there's less
oversight than at a hospital like it's their own private practice.
So they just have all this stuff.
So there's a lot of abuse there that totally makes sense.
Yeah.
You try to find a dentist friend.
I've.
I've always felt that that was the case with cops like cops.
I mean cops have very high suicide rates as well.
I think a lot of his PTSD they're always seeing trauma.
You see these you know but they're also dealing with people that don't want to
see them like all the time.
Yeah most of the time when you you see a cop like all these fucking cop Yeah the
cops are here.
Great you know.
So they just deal with that all the time.
Yeah plus they have a gun on their belt.
So you know that's it could be you know there's gonna be more in your mind if
the gun is constantly there just stick it in your mouth.
Yeah yeah I'm sure.
Yeah.
But they're probably like no one for shooting themselves.
Yeah you know it's easy right there.
You know being a cop is gonna so I don't think anybody is qualified to be a cop.
I really don't.
Not for more than like an hour you know.
Yeah.
You're doing a right along.
No no I have another baby fascinating that anyone can do it right.
It's a pressure.
I feel like you just call the police station and they're right along.
That would be fascinating.
What would you if you do that and the cops get killed and you're in the
backseat.
What can you say.
I'm just on a ride along.
I'm not a cop.
I am white and I'm so sorry for that.
I'm not interested.
I don't want to go to war either.
I won't do a ride along in Afghanistan you know.
I have a friend who just got back from was filming a documentary on Afghanistan
and he was embedded with his troops for over a month and he came back shell
shock.
Really.
Yeah.
He came back just a whacked out and nuts from one month.
Well he was a little more than a month on what seemed like maybe six weeks but
he came back and he was talking about in his his experience when he's a hunter
and he's like there's there's this really creepy similarity that I didn't didn't
take into consideration that these guys are hunting people.
I mean that's really what they're doing.
I mean they're going after like certain you know quote unquote insurgents.
You know you give him some interesting names like insurgents like we never heard
insurgents before this war.
When the fuck did you ever hear.
Did they say insurgents during say the Viet Cong during Vietnam right.
You know they said the Nazis and the Japs during World War 2.
Now it's insurgents.
It's like this real way of making things sanitized.
But he said essentially like he realized like right away.
Like whoa this is like hunting these guys are they're not going after a deer so
they can eat it.
They're going after people and they're there.
They knew their behavior patterns.
They knew how to set traps for them.
They knew where they would be.
They knew how to sneak up on them.
And they had like all these strategies like very similar to the way you would
hunt a deer like OK.
This the path that deer goes into we're going to do is get you know upwind of
them so that or downwind of them so that the weather where the wind comes to us
they can't smell us.
And like all this crazy shit they were doing to try to avoid being seen and
really similar to hunting an animal.
That's crazy.
Yeah he was pretty fucked up.
He came back he was a little a little weird and he had an idea in his head what
it was going to be you know.
He said Well you know go over there do a documentary sort of like you wanted to
you know kind of show how difficult it was.
Show the real side of war.
But you know sort of honor these people that are over there.
He's kind of kind of a simplistic way of looking at things too you know fighting
for our freedom.
He's one of those guys that says Shouldn't you go OK.
What does that mean.
Right.
And they just don't expand like us like fighting for our freedom.
I'm exactly sure.
That exactly what they're doing.
Like they're like people that are telling them to do that.
Are they doing it because they want freedom or is there other ulterior motives
have you looked into this at all.
He didn't you know.
Yeah it's like very surface American Sniper but.
Exactly.
And but when he came back man he had a fucking completely different idea about
it.
He was really he had a very realistic portrayal of war when he came back it was
a fucking eye opener.
Like he was like This is a cluster fuck.
It's a scary cluster fuck and it's not good by any stretch of the imagination
and there's no way to win this fucking thing.
You're over in Afghanistan.
It's all mountains.
There's no towns there's Kabul.
That's one city.
Everything else is warlords who are trapped up in the mountains and get this the
way they get the warlords to tell the Taliban.
Give them via grow Bhangra tigers at best huh.
Give them guns.
You give them money.
They got guns.
They've got some money.
Yeah.
You know they got opium everywhere.
So yeah faggot is the one thing that's not local.
They need Biafra because a lot of these guys are like in their 60s.
They got like 30 wives and these bitches are complaining man you can't fuck them
once a day.
Now once a month it's me a faggot commercial.
Yeah.
Red white and blue line behind the virus.
What's keeping you safe.
It's one of the main ways they get these guys to rat on the Taliban.
That's.
Crazy even call the Taliban anymore they call it al-Qaeda.
Everyone talks about al-Qaida.
It's ISIS now.
It's the same people.
They are their offshoot.
There's their branch of al-Qaeda.
Yeah.
Is it like you know a Van Halen with David Lee Roth was totally different than
Van Halen Sammy Hagar.
Yeah.
Is that what ISIS is like.
They're like a totally different offshoot of the original band.
Yeah we're getting the band back together.
It's ISIL now.
Right.
ISIL ISIL.
Yeah.
Was ISIS.
And now it's aiming for that too.
Yeah they started it ISIS and they changed it.
I saw wasn't 2k wasn't testing it wasn't testing well they rebranded.
Testing testing is adorable.
Take a bunch of people when you doing a television show you take a bunch of
people that don't want to be there.
They're getting paid and then you play a show for the in Vegas.
Yeah it's usually is it really usually.
I think they go to Vegas and they'll they'll you know this like they'll grab
people off the street and they'll be like would you like to see some TV shows
that are about to come out and like you'll get like 20 dollars off TGIF fridays
kind of thing like that and people like Will because they because Vegas is like
where you get a cross-section of everyone from all across the country right.
So they find that you know that you can kind of get people from Iowa you can get
people from Florida and this one like city so you get like a good cross sheet of
what people are gonna think of a show.
That's hilarious.
That's hilarious Vegas.
That's a weird place to do it man.
And it's also like what.
Who are these people like you can't just get a random group of people and ask
them about a show especially if this show is specific you know like of a
specific genre.
Yeah.
No you just get a bunch of rednecks and you play you know some sophisticated
show for them.
This is gay.
Yeah.
Well it's people who are on vacation who have run out of things to do and I'll
just do anything anyone's like OK.
Like if you if you're on vacation at Vegas or something and then somebody was
like Do you want to watch like five TV shows that you've never heard of.
You'd be like No.
Yeah I just think the idea of testing is ridiculous anyway.
This is the way you test it.
Put it on the air.
Yeah.
You know let creative people come up with it.
Let the comedians are the writers or whoever.
Know what.
Whatever kind of show it is.
Let them come up with it.
Put it together and go okay.
We like you let's put this thing on TV and find out you know trust your
instincts on shit.
You don't have to bring this up.
Well we brought you a random group of people need like a wacky neighbor.
Yeah.
How come it isn't a wacky knee or a man.
Well what Amazon does now is they just throw them up online.
Yeah.
And they just see money.
Which one's got the most you know which one the people watch more.
Amazon's got so much goddamn money they can do that.
Yeah they've got drone money.
They're sending drones.
It delivers never going to land.
They're never gonna do I think that was like a publicity stunt that's never
gonna happen.
You don't think so.
No.
Because like if they if Amazon started sending drones there would be guys that
had eight drones in their garage their drones trying to get back to Amazon's
headquarters.
People are gonna steal them.
They're gonna like you know shoot them down take your packages too.
Yeah like this power lines.
How are they gonna get you know.
Well they can see where they're going.
People would steal I'd steal on would you steal a drone.
Yeah.
Be funny how rude Amazon drone.
It's not hurting anyone.
P.S. I mean they find it like find a phone they find your iPhone you don't think
they can find your fucking G.P.S..
Well I'd put it somewhere you know no it wouldn't keep in my house.
Mm hmm.
I lived in a town in Charlottesville I lived in Charlottesville Virginia when I
grew up which is where Dave Matthews was from.
And it was like when Dave Matthews was huge.
And so you know he's like a big thing in my town.
And like one thing that he did to like give back to the community that he wanted
to do was he did this thing where he got a whole bunch of bicycle.
And he painted them like orange and they put him all around town and they're
like these are Dave Matthews is putting all these bikes around and they're free.
You can get one ride it to where you need to go.
Leave it there and then you know you know it's this a community bicycle kind of
thing.
And within like two months they were all gone.
Like all month all gone.
And then for any bikes it was like it was a lot like hundreds of bikes.
They're all gone.
And then and then for like years and years like it cause I was like in like
1920.
Like you know kind of.
You go to house parties and every house party you go to there every one of the
Dave Matthews bikes on the lawn.
I gotta go to Dave's bikes.
You know you can only have what the people that you have.
And that's why they have the Amazon drones because people are going to steal.
That's funny.
Yeah with that you'd a really steal.
That's not something you could borrow Amazon's like I let you borrow their
drones.
No it's got to come to your house right.
Drop off a package.
Yeah but I think it just drops it off then takes off.
I don't think it waits for you to release it.
You know I think it just drops it off and then that's it.
Well you have your buddy order something then you go up on the roof with a
baseball bat.
His wife magically died because you're trying to hit a fucking drone and you
slipped and fell off your roof broke your neck.
That would be a sad funeral stupid fuck.
He died trying to hit a home run off a drone.
I don't know what we're gonna be doing in a few years but I have a feeling that
within the next couple of decades it's not even gonna involve things being
delivered.
I think it's going to involve 3D printing.
Yeah I think that's the big one.
Like you have a subscription to like Apple or something like that.
And then you you know you have their account and then they just make your iPod
in your living room kind of thing.
Yeah.
You know how like you order like a movie on iTunes you say hey I want to watch
taken or whatever and just click it and then all the movie will you start
downloading and then you start watching it.
I think that's what it's gonna be like.
I want a new pair of Converse chucks right now and then I want to feel build a
3D print cloth.
That's an interesting question.
Mm hmm.
Possibly.
Why not.
Right.
Yeah.
Mm hmm.
Because it's woven like this the whole idea of cloth as a whole maybe like some
sort of like what are the sham wow kind of course not that I'm comfortable but
Blizzard show is a sham me like a sham is a skin of an animal like it's a super
absorbent skin of an animal.
And I'm sure they have synthetic I think that I think that whatever chamois was
I don't think it was an animal.
What does that 3D printed for fabrics.
Well let me just fucking answer a question crazy.
How does that shit work.
You know it's crazy is when I look at this
when the 3D printing like takes off is like you know what happened with like
music and like the entertainment where I've seen people could like BitTorrent
everything.
You're gonna have that happen to every single industry because all of a sudden
you can you can bit torn an iPhone.
You can put that whole thing like you wouldn't download a car would you be like
well if it was possible.
Yes a lot of people would as you will be able to do it.
Yeah that that argument for piracy.
I had Paul Stanley from KISS and who's like really adamant that it's stealing
it's stealing.
And I was like you know it's piracy.
I'm like making a copy is it.
Yeah.
It's the original still there.
Like it's not really stealing you know.
But he's he's used to being rich and wants to stay rich and he wants to keep
making millions of dollars.
But he was talking about how the industry just disappeared and I was like well
it's kinda but see my argument was like Yeah but the radio always existed and
you were you always had radio and you play the music on radio and that's what
made the music famous.
And then people would go out and buy the C.D.
and you'd make millions and then they would go out and tour and you'd make more
millions.
Well now one part of that's missing right.
The buying it is missing and people don't really want to buy it anymore but they
still want to tour.
They'll still buy T-shirts that's always room money came from anywhere it's
T-shirts like you know these people tour and they you know I mean like back in
like the old Sun Records days and everything they were on the road all the time
you know putting out these singles and then making all their money touring and
just kind of go back to that.
Well I think the record companies have forked way more than the artists.
Yeah because that's why the record companies are creating these like really
fucking strange deals especially like with young artists they get talked into
these really creepy deals where you know they get locked up for X amount of
years and they're really like strange contracts like that established artists
would never agree to and then you have to try to get out of them once you get to
a certain point but they're just trying to figure out a way to lock down these
artists and try to suck money out of them.
Where.
I mean what do they have to offer these days.
They don't really have anything.
It used to be like you needed a record company to release your record and they
get you on the radio.
But now the radio doesn't mean shit.
Now everyone just wants to get in like a TV show or like in a commercial now.
I mean that's like the song that's payday.
Yeah.
It's just getting like your song played at the end of some MTV show or getting
like your song played in the background of a commercial that's like the the new.
Yeah.
Or just getting it like okay.
Like how about that Gangnam Style guy like that guys in a weird spot because
everybody knows you ain't gonna make more in one of those dude.
I think you're right.
He got that one song where no one knows what the fuck you're singing.
Yeah and people go is kind of catchy.
And how many of those can you make man.
And do people want to go see you live.
Well he's a big guy in Korea.
Yeah yeah he's a he's a B he was a big he was a star before that over there and
this was just I think went international.
But the size how big that song was he didn't need to have another one.
You think so.
I think he'll be able to coast off that for a while.
You think how much money you think they make.
Jamie's like he's fine.
Plus that.
I mean there was on that was on so many commercials too.
And then like ten years from now there'll be a nostalgia for it.
It'll come back.
Really.
Oh like Rick Astley.
Yeah.
Rock Roll yeah yeah.
Oh man I don't know.
E You gotta think that
like for most artists that's not going to happen right.
Maybe for him but for most artists.
They got a hit.
You've got a few songs that people are into and then you're hoping they can come
see you live.
Yeah that's like the big thing.
Yeah but with Paul Stanley he was just saying that you used to be able to make a
lot of money off the sales of the records and now it doesn't exist anymore
because of illegal downloads but they must be making some money right off of.
I tunes and shit yeah I think I mean I'm sure it's it was better.
Yeah for the few people that like you know.
You know we're in the Paul Stanley level you know.
But I don't know.
That's flipside of that is that there's a lot of smaller bands that can you know
get heard now.
Like you know the Internet's been great for small music I mean you have a
platform I can I guess know I don't know.
I think it broke it broke up the monopoly broke up that industry which is a
really creepy industry guy dude.
All right I'm gonna get that robot.
Dave he's gonna suck.
Can't help it.
You watch that movie artifact about 30 seconds to mars.
What is the label battle.
Oh that's the Jared Leto thing as I say let go let a little.
It's it's an insane movie talking exactly about why you're talking about the
really famous band that went on tour sold out everything and they came back in
the record label said they stole a million dollars.
No.
What the fuck.
How they.
It's a whole three year battle and the documentary shows everything lawyer
talks.
Wow.
And meanwhile no one's talking about that documentary.
It's not like yet it hasn't.
I mean they still ended up at the end of the movie and spoiler alert.
Right.
They're still making music right now.
This is a couple of years ago.
The movie was made.
Did you ever see the piece that Courtney Love wrote on a music business that
sort of highlights how crazy it is.
Like how much money goes to the record company versus how much goes to the
artist.
But again that was before the internet kind of like took the legs out from under
that business.
Yeah.
Napster for comics it's giant.
We never made any money off of seeds anyway.
I mean you make a little bit.
But the real money was always in doing clubs and doing theatres and stuff like
that.
So the Internet is just awesome promotion for that like way better than anything
else before way better than radio.
Way better than putting out a C.D..
There is nothing better than the internet.
I mean guys I mean that blows my mind.
I try to think about like what you know.
You have a mailing list you know you know at the end of a show you put out a pad
of paper and you know like write down you know I'll send out a mailing list
every year.
Let you know when I was a kid I'd go to the record store and just check to see
if the bands that I like had new albums out because there was no way to know
like you know you would just go and sometimes you know you'd check multiple
times a year and then you'd like oh there's a new there's no way to tell.
That's right.
Yeah.
You know where they would have like a poster up.
Coming September 3rd.
The new Bon Jovi.
Did you hear.
You know and then the radio would have to tell you this information was really
hard to get back then man.
It's really hard to get anything you know yet.
You got like I remember I was in the KISS Army.
You know you get like a Kiss Kiss fan thing in the mail.
When I was a kid and you'd get like this but you know I only remember them
saying tour dates just tell you about the band you know.
You know you get this like real superficial version of who they are.
So so much different now so much different.
You can't be like this mysterious hidden person in a castle.
Marilyn Manson style top of the hill cowlick.
They know you now man.
If they don't know you they're not going to.
It's just to hold animals.
Different people are different.
Like I think human beings.
I think we're so used to it.
It's hard for us to really conceptualize.
It's hard for us to really kind of appreciate how much different just
interacting with human beings is today.
In 2015 as opposed to like 1985.
Well I I was we were shooting Whitest Kids.
When the iPhone came out and we were in production you know and I remember like
me and a guy Zach from the troop would direct everything.
So I remember directing you know we like mid season.
And the day before the iPhone came out you know everyone would kind of be
talking you know in between takes like everyone would be on set like you know
P.A.
is like you know like a caution department we would kind of be like joking
around and stuff like that.
And then the iPhone came out at midnight and like you know it was a huge thing.
Everybody would wait in line.
A lot of people got it and the next day everybody was just staring at the iPhone
and it was this thing where I was like I was crazy because I bought one too and
I was like It's just crazy with this thing can do and it's everybody sort of
fascinated with what this can do but we never went back.
It was it never went back.
I thought it was just gonna be like a couple days where everyone's just you know
staring at this thing and it was like that was the dividing point.
It changed after that.
Now you know just interacting interacting with people is just completely
different.
Well then the social media really took off because you took it everywhere with
you.
It wasn't like well when I get home then I will check my social media.
I'll check my MySpace page or whatever.
No I wasn't that it was like you're on the road you're everywhere you go you're
eating dinner you know you're in your car at stoplights you're looking at your
your Twitter feed.
Yeah you know you see people that are just glued to it.
They can't have a conversation.
I have some people that come on the podcast and they're we're in the middle of
conversations and then you start.
Yeah yeah.
Oh yeah.
They're not even listening.
They don't even paying attention that I can sound like they can't help it man.
They can't help it.
There's this weird like poll it just did that.
Maybe there's some interesting and for most of time there's not most of time
it's not.
It's like you're searching for a present.
Like maybe there's one more Christmas present or that tree is gonna find that
present but it's not there.
It's very rare that you like your obsession pays off when you're like staring at
social media.
Yeah it's very rare that it is worth the look we're just looking to see what
your friends are doing or thinking but like you don't care what your friends are
doing or thinking like it's cool to call you.
Yeah.
You know hey man something fucking crazy happened.
Yeah but now it's like you're constantly looking for more data and I think the
newness of it is like really attracted attractive to us in a way that we have a
really hard time controlling you know or it's just the beginning of its
metamorphosis it's the beginning of evolution like to us becoming like a
synthetic kind of non carbon based you know silicone based being kind of thing
and you know then we put nanobots in ourselves and you know it's just the first
step that you know of of evolving.
Yeah I think so.
I think that's most definitely what it is.
There was a article recently.
I think yesterday about this guy was dying of cancer leukemia I believe and
they're going he's gonna be the first person they inject nanobots into.
Well yeah it's as fuck and it's it's begun.
These tiny little robots try to like without it he's going to die.
So let's give it a shot.
And I've heard that's supposed to be the norm within like 15 years.
What if this dude becomes Dr. Manhattan just like all figures out everything
starts glowing blue he sees Dick everywhere he goes yeah.
I think I think human beings will definitely have some sort of a weird symbiotic
relationship with computers in within the next like decade though they'll be
implants that you'll be able to get data directly downloaded into your brain.
I mean I think it's it's only a matter of time before they do that.
Well they're saying I think I was reading some of this in the nanobots thing is
gonna be commonplace within like 15 years where you know you inject them and
deal and then just constantly is doing read outs like oh your platelets are low
Oh your white blood cells are well like and it's just telling like your doctor
so you can you know keep up with everything.
Kurzweil believes within the next few decades you're gonna have nanobots that
are going to allow you to hold your breath for over an hour.
They're going to give you these nanobots that somehow or another do something
with maybe artificial blood cells or some like that where they can hold and
carry oxygen through your system so well that you'll be able to take a deep
breath jump to the bottom the pool and sit there for an hour like a regular
person that's fucking fucking crazy.
No we're worrying about a drowning for your friend.
Yeah dummy holds breath hold your breath then walk back just get on a ground on
the bottom of the ocean and walk home.
There's that's awesome.
Well there's already experiments where they've transmitted words from one person
to another person in their brain through the Internet.
Really.
Yeah yeah.
They transmitted a word from one part.
Jamie pull it up because it's kind of difficult to describe.
Exactly what they did but somehow or another like say if you're thinking
Christmas tree you know you you actually can send that word to me through the
Internet and somehow or another I receive it.
I'm not sure I understand.
Yeah.
Is it is it is it visualized.
It's like look at the signs.
Scientists transmit thoughts from one brain to another international team of
scientists has succeeded in transmitting the thoughts of one individual into the
brain of a second person located thousands of miles away.
Combining some of the latest technological marvels with the long arm of the
Internet is thought to be the first time the two brains have communicated with
each other directly over long distance without the sender having to utter a
single word to greetings Oh la and Chow Oh I can't even do it in America using
English requires made a historic trip from India to France where oh excuse me
France where they were received and spoken by a researcher who was blindfolded
and equipped with earplugs.
Wow.
Scientists want to ensure that the receiver knew what his colleague 5000 miles
away was thinking because of the brain to brain transmission not because of some
other cue.
That's amazing.
So somehow or another those two words were transmitted and they knew what those
two words were thousands of miles.
I don't get it man.
But it sounds good right.
But like it you told me 30 years ago that there were gonna be able to send a
video through the mail.
I believe.
What are you even talking about.
Or through the air on a phone.
Yeah.
Like what.
What's a video you're going to feel a sense of.
A video that you could if you're watching it on what you got on TV.
Wait a minute hold on.
So to a TV show is gonna be on what you're gonna hold on to something like in
Star Trek.
They didn't even have fucking.
If you look at those stupid phones that they had they didn't have buttons on
them.
They were just like Kirk out like the.
The space ship had to know that they were calling Kirk but Kirk called a
spaceship and that's it.
He couldn't call his girlfriend.
He couldn't get his a man.
You guys won't eat like there wasn't any of that going on.
Like they didn't even think that would be possible.
Yeah.
They thought that they'd be able to bring you to break your body down until like
subatomic particles and reconstruct you on the surface of an alien planet like
that makes sense.
But you got a walkie talkie or some the USA Kirk out you know Kirk out here you
couldn't even could even see call ended on your phone.
Yeah.
We don't even have any idea what they're gonna be able to figure out within the
next few years.
Like the concept of transmitting a word through the Internet and the US
understanding what that word is to you and I.
It's like what are you talking about.
But 10 20 years from now they may be like of course you do that.
That's what you do.
I send words to each other it be terrible if like it ends up being like a
Twitter thing where it's just like you know everybody's stupid
like went to the mall.
Is this constantly rattling around your brain.
Do you think that Twitter is making people stupid.
Now I get it some people stupid right.
I think it's just I mean
I don't think it makes people stupid.
I think it just like you know it's just more distractions.
Yeah.
Well you know what is the weirdest thing to me.
There's some people that use Twitter and it seems like everything they're
posting there they're like manipulating what they think or what they're saying
they're manipulating it in order to get a positive reaction from people.
You know I almost feel like they're not really communicating.
They're like selling themselves.
Yeah you know they're like faking it.
I always feel that like when like a celebrity dies like and then everybody posts
like oh my god this guy meant this to me or this to me this to me this to me
this to me and like I get it.
You know but like it always seems to be about themselves kind of in a weird way
where it's like this is how much this affected my life and exactly or like any
sort of issue that people like.
There's like a bandwagon of everybody jumping on like we got to find Kony.
You know we got to find county and you know like that and this is your entire
timeline.
It's just everybody talking about Kony.
I mean you watched the video.
And that went away immediately because the guy jerked off in public.
That's it.
Yeah.
That's all I got to do is run around his underwear in San Diego beaten off in a
street losing his mind and they were like This is meanwhile this is just the
messenger the guy Kony was still a piece of shit.
Still a bad guy in Africa murdering people and shit and everybody's like Yeah
but that guy was beaten off and on to be a part of this.
Well the weird thing the weird thing about the Kony thing for me was like when.
Because it came out of nowhere.
It was just everybody being like Kony going to go any like you know and and then
you're like OK well that seems like an asshole.
You know child army never good you know and then you look in and you like so
what are you doing.
They're like Well we want to get the United States involved and send troops over
there and like Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hold on.
You know a couple of countries are already doing that.
Where do we need to be adding the thing to get after one guy because he fits on
a bumper sticker.
Yeah.
Come on in 2012.
And I'm pretty sure if we go over there we're not going to grab all those kids
and put them in the school.
I think we're going to probably you know kill all his kids.
You know that's kind of what we do.
We don't shoot at us.
We're gonna shoot back.
We're super sorry.
But we had to save those kids by shoot them.
Yeah.
The Kony 2012 and the ice bucket challenge.
They they both had that thing in common where I felt like there was an
insincerity to the message that people were sending out through social media
like they were sending it out to get social media brownie points.
He wanted everyone to know that their super conscious and super progressive.
And there's that that's one of the things that drives me nuts.
There's certain Twitter pages that I'll visit.
One of them recently blocked me because I've mocked him on on the podcast.
Hilarious by the way.
Dummy don't you know that all I have to do is log out and I could still see your
Twitter page you dipshit.
It's public.
Just type it into a browser and read all your stupidity.
But this guy's entire Twitter page is like telling people how they should be
living and telling people what's wrong with the way other people are living and
what's wrong with the way other people are thinking and what's so bad about
certain social issues.
It's hilarious.
Like don't you have sandwiches that you like.
Isn't there like a movie you enjoyed.
Did you have a great time.
Did you have a revelation today.
Did you feel bad about something maybe you thought.
Did you have any.
Is there any unique insight as to you as a human being or is your whole thing
like just lessons to other people.
Yeah like everybody needs to learn and this is what's wrong with this and this
is what's wrong with that and it's all like that those type of people are almost
all either like extreme right wing like like real like heavy duty Republicans
like there's one dumb ass that I go to.
He but he's a young earth Christian guy and you know it's everything in his
entire timeline is anti-Obama anti liberal anti-gay.
So is this anti dinosaur.
And then this other guy go to the extreme left wing and everything that he does
is like super progressive super like really like Uber left wing Uber socially
conscious to the point where I'm not buying it.
You sound you know you're not even a human right.
You're like a sounding board you've made across this issue.
Yeah.
You made activism your personality.
Exactly.
That's a great way to put it.
You've made activism your personal.
It's a great way to put it.
And it's not really activism.
It's just talking.
Yeah.
Just yapping and bitching about shit.
You know either bitching about shit or proclaiming the right way to be and it's
always like you know pro transgender pro gay pro.
It's like I can I can guess.
Like super easy what your position is gonna be on anything.
It's gonna be like super uber left wing like down the pipe every time no nuance
no subtlety to it.
Like you're going to subscribe to whatever the agenda is or subscribe to
wherever the ideology you know fits.
There's a fetish ization of being outraged or being offended you know for a lot
of like on both sides of the aisle.
The thing where you've you know you you mean there's genuine outrage and there's
genuine being offended at things that there should be.
You know you should be offended by it but then there's some of these people that
you see it's this seems like well you're kind of reaching direct creation to be
offended.
Yeah yeah they're looking for it.
Yeah there is a lot of reaching but there's also I think a lot of it is people
just getting used to this new ability to communicate and they're finding that I
think for some of these people some of these people are severely socially
retarded and they're finding that they can get love and support when they say
things that other folks who agree with.
So then that's all they say they're all they're doing is like saying things they
think other people agree with.
Yeah and they'll just sound these things out and say them.
And that's like most of it is like da you know like there's a lot of stuff like
you know like we should be we should end sexual discrimination of course.
Yeah like who the fuck doesn't he.
Is that really going to end sexual discrimination by writing about it on
Twitter.
If there was a vote yeah like it's gonna be 99 percent of people that say you
check yes we should end sexual discrimination yes.
You know there's a recent study that showed that most people that work out and
exercise he's backing up sucking on that robot.
Here here here at home
I'm gonna get you one of these dude.
Please don't make any sound bro you just get a fucking cut your hands up while
you carry it.
So he's sharp edges that is sharp edges.
You know you could use this for if you a particularly tough cut of meat roll
this fucker all over the meat and it would really soften it up nicely
tenderizer.
Yeah it's a meat tenderizer.
I mean it really is.
If you didn't have a meat tenderizer in your house you could absolutely use this
giant hunk of copper fucking weight often found.
Yeah but I think oh shit I put it in the wrong spot.
I put it put it heads down.
Heads up it's a piece of shit exercise I go over Senate House fire with that you
left it on up overnight and then the whole copper heats up and just burns
through your table you know it happened it would make weird noises and then your
cat would come over and your cat would touch it with his paw and then you would
burst into flames and then he would jump on the couch freaking out trying to
enter the couch you go up and then your fucking whole house is on the phone it's
a Ben Stiller movie it's just like two minutes.
Yeah it was Morgan Adam Sandler movie.
No more Ben Stiller right.
Maybe Will Ferrell.
Yeah oh say Will Ferrell.
I think that the the Internet and the ability to communicate.
It's so fresh that there's all these like archetype like stereotypical sort of
characters that have come up like the right wing guy like you know who's a great
one to follow Chuck Woolery the guy.
Oh yeah.
To and to be right back into it too.
Yeah that guy does his pitch about Obama.
Yeah.
All day it's all about the Dems.
He writes things like anybody.
You're right the Dems you're an idiot.
You're right the Dems or the Libs you're retarded OK.
No bama.
Yeah.
No bomb Obama.
But he.
All he does is complain about Obama all day all day his fucking entire twitter
feed is complaining about the liberals.
You know meanwhile it's like living in Texas and bass fishing and whining and in
doing commercials for like prostate pills.
Does he do.
I mean I feel like a lot of those guys do like does he have a radio show.
I don't think he does.
Does he.
Is he auditioning for a radio show is that what the Twitter feed is.
Here's his.
Oh he has a fucking salary.
Save us Chuck.
No it isn't.
Oh come on.
I did that.
I did his show.
BECK Got a second look at this today on save us.
Chuck get the fuck out of here.
That's his show.
That is so rude us.
The idea that you would call your show save us Chuck political satire from a
Hollywood confirmed Oh my God oh it's political satire.
Is that what it is.
You know it'd be better if somebody like onion style made a save us Chuck and
just mocked it openly like nothing ever gets saved from an old actor.
I mean don't you play any of it.
Jamie.
He's probably going to run for congressmen or something wherever he live game
show legend Chuck Woolery considers why Democrats are willing to support
Boehner.
Why.
Bob Bob blow by blow on NASA and global warming.
When your government is in charge of your fund when the government is in charge
of your funding you tow the company line just like all government funded
science.
What does that mean.
Does he mean he doesn't believe in global making.
Course you don't.
That's an ideological thing.
The right wing are reluctant to agree in climate change being something that's a
product of human beings.
No he is he ran for president.
It says if you elect me president my press secretary would be oh my god is he
serious.
Oh I hope that any right.
If you in gigantic capital letters write in their eyes and write him in.
That would be.
Great.
I always felt like you seem like a nice guy when he's on that show.
I did his show.
I did the dating game when I was 18 years old.
No I was I came I was doing.
I did stand up at the Laugh Factory when I was 18 and they had scouts in the
dating game in the audience and they were like I guess at that time they were
doing two contestants and then the third contestant was always a comedian.
So they were going and trying to find the kids that were doing standup and like
fish that you won't be on the dating game so I got to go do what was that like.
It was weird.
I mean it was it was actually really like
because of laws or whatever they had to make sure that everything is as it seems
as they say so you're not allowed to see the other contests that you're not
allowed to see the girl.
Right.
So they have people following you around with walkie talkies like you know make
sure you don't let a contested number three is on the way to the bathroom.
You know make sure that you know so it's really like there was a lot of
security.
Wow that is interesting what is did you meet Chuck.
You hang with him about the lives.
No I he.
I met him when the show started and when know it is a perfect ticket.
Chuck Woolery Ted Nugent together at last.
Come on.
I'd vote for it would you.
Just to see what happens.
Yeah I would like to.
I would vote for some ridiculous like that if they'd gotten office and see
things go exactly the same way they've always gone.
Like just like Obama.
Yeah that's the kind of thing I would be really fascinated with.
Yeah like you know it'd be like I bet you know like really see like how much
power the president actually has.
You know I would love to see what happens if you didn't do the social stuff
those dangerous that did the real danger with things like.
Like when really hardcore Republicans get in.
It's like things like gay rights abortion rights like things though along those
lines.
That is a real.
Like like marijuana legalization and the support of the DEA raiding medical
marijuana.
I guess that's real that's real.
Like they really do have an impact on social issues.
Supreme Court justices.
Yeah that's a big that's a big that's a big power the president has but yeah I'm
choosing those right wing fuckheads who barely believe in evolution.
If they said well you can vote for a starfish and a puppy and just see what
happens I'd bet a lot of people
we would go to war with Iran the next day.
Starfish heads I ran the bubbles with it would be the president of starfish or
the puppy.
Yeah well the crazy thing is they're talking about Jeb Bush and Hillary Clinton.
That is terrifying me insane because doesn't it feel like you know you're.
Oh the whole thing's fake.
Yes.
The whole thing.
Oh I mean you kind of felt that the whole time.
But isn't this like this is the smoking gun like oh it's all rigged.
It's all it's all been a trick like.
I mean Clinton for eight years old Bush for four and then young Bush for eight.
We got Obama.
Okay we got a new name.
And then what is Obama's wife going to run next year or the kids.
Yeah well Hillary you get Chelsea Clinton then you've got nobody but they really
do.
They've got another.
They've got a brand new Bush down in Texas.
They've got one.
Yeah.
Who's the new deal or something.
He just ran for Treasury or something and he won and he's and he's he's young
and he's handsome and he's like there they're saying like he's like the next in
Q Oh God Neil Bush.
No that's not Neil.
That's another one.
He's fairly you up like Texas.
Midland Texas.
It's recent.
Mm hmm.
How many bushes are there.
Neil Bush and his family.
Mary it's not Neil it's commuting.
George scary ass robots.
It's.
He's a Texas he he just won election like this year last year.
Chuck Woolery that's who I'm voting for.
God damn it.
Just save us Chuck.
We'll be right back and to and to end those fucking press conferences like that.
Oh God.
So I wonder if he would be terrified if he won the presidency just being like oh
like I wonder if he would realize that he's not
probably capable of being president or if you're just not not get it all just be
like I should be president.
I think he probably thinks you should be president.
Yeah.
Ted Nugent thinks he should be president.
He's a narcissism thing.
Does the idea that I should be in charge is all presidents are probably crazy.
I don't think anybody should be president.
I really don't think that it should be an option.
I say a computer.
Yeah I mean can't.
Well we will probably get there in the next 20 years we have a computer we
program in all of our laws you know and we were like Okay now you know make the
right choice.
Yeah but it's program by people and people can influence the programming.
I mean that was one of the big devil deals with electronic voting machines.
Right now we have that computer be built by a computer.
But then we're fucked because of computers is going to take over then it's like
what.
Elon Musk is worried about George P.
Bush.
You look at that that's going to be the next well he's going to get a lazy eye.
The left eye Kennedy somebody punched him.
Can you get a lazy eye.
Yeah I did it to grow at a lazy eye and I found lazy eye sexy for a short period
of time.
She was kind of a freak.
She's a frequent lazy guy.
I developed a lazy eye fetish for at least a year.
Did you.
Miss it.
Yeah.
So very small you porn search.
Well wired glasses hot girls with glasses are hot.
You know girls are crushes aren't hot.
Like why is some disabilities hot.
Mm hmm.
You know a girl with glasses is something sexy about you like there's like a
library.
It's like a older authority figure.
Glasses or authority.
Who is.
Mm hmm.
Someone is reading so much their eyes go bad.
You know that hot bitch came.
See.
Plus he could take your glasses off your ugly shoes even No.
She could feel you though if you're fat and ugly like Damn she you feel me.
She can't grow the glasses and no hands.
You feel your weight on it.
As she wraps her legs around.
I was all fucking fat slob like what you thought.
You don't have hands.
Medium picky for
fetishes are weird man.
I had a foot fetish too when I was a kid.
For a little while I got rid of it.
That's a popular one.
I don't get it.
I don't get that one but it's I need is one girl when you're like 18 to play
with your dick with her feet and then you're gone and you're good.
Now it's over.
Need is one bad Nanny.
Growing up you got.
Yeah.
There was I mean a lot to talk about it in my act.
There was a magazine which found the woods once when I was a kid.
It was called it was Foot Action magazine and it was me and his two friends mine
and my friend Josh and my friend my friend Pedro and we're we're going over
these these magazines like some dude left a magazine bag like like a plastic bag
under a log.
When you're a kid and you're in the woods and you find magazines it's almost
always porn.
Yeah.
And so we're going through this magazine and it was just like gnomes talking
because it was it was all like foot stuff.
You know it's like weird.
And then like three minutes and my friend goes Dude this shit is all just dicks
and feet.
I'll never forget.
I'll never forget him saying that I never forget those words coming out of his
mouth because we were totally quiet.
Well we're like we're confused because we're only 11.
Yeah and he's like Dude this shit is all just dicks and feet and articles.
There's no art.
You know obviously again pre internet you know any eleven year old kid is
probably seen hours of hardcore ass porn.
Yeah.
I just think it's so crazy that there is a time where there's like you know guys
we just go out into the woods with a foot magazine and just turn off and leave
it there like that's like the scariest person I can think of.
Meanwhile there's probably someone listening to us right now with earbuds
jerking off to a flip magazine.
Yes.
We thought that we were hey you know.
I mean you get enough numbers you know you get like a million people that listen
to a podcast at once you know there's gonna be one dude out there jerking off to
a foot magazine.
Yeah.
You looked at a there's a million.
That's one of the bigger fetishes isn't it.
Probably pretty big.
Yeah.
But like what.
What is it.
What are their big fetishes like.
Big girls.
Some guys like really big girls.
Yeah.
There's all those kids that dress up like animals vs.
furries.
Have you ever seen them.
Oh my dear life.
I went.
I've never.
I mean I.
We were playing a festival in Atlanta and it was the furry convention in town
same day.
And we were all in the same hotel room and we had driven we had driven from
Florida.
We had just done a show in Florida and then we were sketched out by the hotel
that was provided for us.
We're like we're just gonna fucking drive like Atlanta.
So we drove all night so we got into the hotel was so sketchy you drove all
night.
There was there was there was blood.
We flip the mattress over and there was blood.
On the bottom of it and put back.
No I mean we felt below a reason there.
So we're like fuck this for driving Atlanta.
So we drove like all night.
And then we get in and we're like we're all almost like delirious like tired.
So I get into hotel and then we're seeing all these furries everywhere as
artifact and your mascot convention.
Yeah yeah well the weird thing is like kids are coming up to him because the
kids see like you know it's a mascot and they're like hugging I'm like don't hug
that costume.
It's not goofy but I checked into my room and there was you know the whole the
most of the hotel running by furries and there was the loudest like sex going on
like against the wall while I was trying to sleep and all I wanted to do is like
midday and I just want to get like a couple hours of sleep for the show that
night.
And it's just like loud sex and then these guys just getting in fights being
like I would never I would never this repeating that again and again I would
never like you know like.
And then just more sex kind of stuff.
And it was.
That's my only encounter at first.
Oh oh I stumbled upon one as well.
In Pittsburgh I was in Pittsburgh and apparently that's one of the places where
they have big they used to have a big one in San Diego.
But they moved it to Pittsburgh as Pittsburgh is more open minded than San
Diego.
That didn't make any sense to me.
This guy was telling me they might be bullshit me but apparently San Diego is
like a pretty conservative town and a lot of ways right.
A lot of military down there.
Well you put a furry convention in the military community that's probably not.
Kelly I'd never seen it in person and it was just total dumb luck that we were
in town the exact same time and when we got to our hotel the people that were
working there were except tactic to talk to people that weren't furries and
wanted to tell you all the things that furries were asking for.
Oh wow.
And one of the crazy things they were asking for they want all their food and
bowls.
They want to eat on the ground like a dog.
And they asked like room service they could deliver their food in bowls like
milk.
They wanted milk in a bowl like a dog.
So they could drink out of it and they wonder a litter box in the hallway.
They asked for a litter box in the lobby.
Big I draw a line there like they will.
Well the guy was like What.
And I said hold on.
The guy asked you to put a litter bottle like a regular sized litter box.
No they wanted a large box.
They wanted to pay to have a large litter box installed in the lobby and his
that their thoughts were hey we have this whole hotel we bought bought out the
whole hotel wasn't the hotel I was in the hotel too right.
But there was a few other people that weren't furry.
So we went to shit in the lobby they wanted to shit in the lobby that's in there
at least pee like they asked the guy.
I mean he could've been they could've been pulling the guy's leg but I guarantee
you if the guy said yes somebody would have shit in that lobby Oh yeah somebody
if they had like a big like sandbox like the one on ones that kid's playing fill
with cat litter.
I love
it.
I love going to like different like groups message boards and just like hanging
out on him like lurking on I'm just reading them and it's like one of my fair
things to do at night.
And I've been on like furry ones before and it's like they're like serious about
that stuff.
It's insane.
It's like it's like and that is it is a very new thing.
Mm hmm yeah.
Something happened.
I don't know if it's Wi-Fi signals or cell phone service but something this is
something did something about vaccines.
Yeah.
Jenny McCarthy is right.
What if it's some there's the other thing these spirit animals like people like
like I'm a fox kin like foxes my spider.
Yeah.
And other candidates planet kids there's girls who think they do a song about it
on the new album.
I do a song called Bullies where the whole point of the song is like you know it
means cracking down on these bullies but like Okay fine.
Bullies are bad.
But like if the bullies go away we're screwed because people are gonna get out
of get faster keeping you in line.
Like you know when I was a kid I you know I.
You go away for the summer you know you don't see your friends so much like
that.
And so I was really into Ninja Turtles and like and so then when it gets to be
around like 13 or years old like I come back to school form and into turtle toys
you know thinking that everybody's gonna like you know be still in the Ninja
Turtles and then everybody just made fun of me.
All right.
We do.
Toys like and there's like okay.
Good.
Duly noted.
Got rid of them and it was fine.
Like you know because the bullies kept me alive they kind of told me like that's
not cool.
Yeah they mock you.
Yeah.
When I was a kid I was eleven and I moved from Florida to Boston and I just
wasn't
11 12 and 13 yeah about 13 and I guess I was in middle school and I went to this
I was in Jamaica Plain which is kind of now it's become more gentrified.
When I lived there it was priest you like late 7 these early.
Like maybe 1980 at the latest 1980 I think high school freshman year was eighty
one for me.
So I guess it was like nineteen seventy nine or 1980 and I had like an
incredible hulk lunchbox.
And you know and when you're in a fuckin you know quote unquote urban middle
school and you show up with a fucking cartoon lunchbox you get shit all over.
I had I had that lunchbox for one day.
I remember like I was so happy I got this lunchbox so we'd like to recite a love
of the Hulk and they fucking looked at me like I was like a victim.
I got ready.
I was gonna get attacked like I was a limping antelope straying in front of a
waterfall of the herd.
And I was I realized I got to get rid of this thing.
I remember thinking myself I got to leave it in a locker somewhere.
Yeah I got to take this lunchbox and just leave it somewhere I can even bring it
home because like I'm in danger carrying it around like carrying a relic I it
was a target.
Yeah.
None of the other kids had lunchboxes with like cartoon like there was no
innocence at all.
It was non-existent.
It was like a dangerous creepy school environment an area walking room was
working and.
But if you didn't have that experience you could be dressing up like Hulk today
being in a hotel room with like a condo.
Yeah but it's not bad.
I mean comic con.
I've never been.
I've been to San Diego why it was happening.
I feel like they're having a good time you know.
Yeah.
And I think there's a huge difference between the cause players and Comic Con
and furries.
What's the difference.
I don't.
I think that they'll backtrack.
I mean no I'll stick with it.
I'll stick with it.
Okay let's explore this.
It's well I don't think I think the furry thing and I'm probably wrong but the
the you know quick take that I get away from it is that it seems to be a lot
about sex.
You know like dressing up and having sex with other animals.
They defend that though.
Yeah.
If you bring them up to furries I said No it's not about that furries contact me
because we shit on them in a podcast because you know I've heard that as well
and they say it's not about that.
Yeah but that's what people say about anything.
True.
But don't want to ever admit it's just about sex but we're.
Oh yeah.
But on the other hand now I'm not even like doubting myself I mean I'm playing
devil's advocate for myself even if it is about that and it is a person who
wants to dress up like a animal and then fuck another guy dressed like an animal
who gives a shit really I mean I think it's weird but like you know it doesn't
bother me and it doesn't affect me at all.
It's voluntary.
Yeah those things are voluntary.
Who cares.
You could be weird and voluntary.
It's not a bad thing to want to fuck a mascot.
You know why is that awful.
But it's also not bad I think it's weird.
Yeah it's not bad.
It's deadly not bad I think it's weird but there's a lot of weird shit that we
just accept like what's up with like garter belts.
Like why do people like like thigh high stockings and you know right elastic
bands connect your underwear to your stock what the fuck is all that about.
That's weird shit to Yeah.
Why was that hot.
Yeah yeah lingerie then I don't get it.
Mm hmm.
So oh jesus christ I did it again.
I set this fucking shitty thing down and it's hot as fuck.
Every time I do it I'm going gonna burn the studio to the ground.
The studio is going down but if you look at it like that it's like I look like a
lunar module or something.
Yeah.
It looks like a miniature from like an old sci fi film.
I've never seen one so stupid I've seen a bunch of these things I've never seen
one this dumb.
Or this like a flash gordon dildo.
I just can't understand why anybody would make it so hard to hold on to like the
idea that it's so sharp edged.
Yeah.
How did that happen.
It did not come from what the giant vape thing.
How come they have the little e-cigarettes and the little e-cigarettes where it
looked like a cigarette.
Now it turned out like black ones like you murdered out.
You get a murdered cigarette it's all back.
Back down.
And then it turned into these goddamn robot.
I think it's all battery life.
I think it's because the batteries in these things.
You know I think this will last like a day.
You know you can kind of hit it all day.
That's it.
Yeah.
That only lasts a data.
How many times a day do you hit that thing constantly.
And you were smoking how much was a pack a day for a while and then I switched
to this and I bet my nicotine levels through the roof.
I bet I bet I do.
I take in more nicotine now than I when I smoked a pack a day but nicotine is
not necessarily what's dangerous.
Well it turns out great for you.
I mean it'll raise your blood pressure.
You know you still got.
Yeah.
You still have it.
You still got problems with like heart attack stroke kind of things like that
but it's very real.
Yeah.
Because it raises it's a stimulant so it raises your blood pressure.
You've got a really jack it up all day though.
Yeah.
That kind of response don't you.
Which I do.
I do like
that.
But like as far as carcinogens I think it's pretty clear as far as they know
right now.
Did you ever see that.
RUSSELL CROWE He's backing up here it.
Try to keep it quiet.
Well no we don't.
Don't worry about it man.
Was that Russell Crowe movie The Insider is that what it was.
Yeah.
Where he was a scientist that worked for the cigarette companies and was he was
testifying about all the different chemicals that they put.
Yeah.
That's terrifying shit.
They had a number of chemicals.
They allowed the FDA allowed five hundred and ninety nine plus chemicals.
I mean I remember I was just talk about this last week where there's I remember
when I was a kid you know you download like Anarchist Cookbook and all stuff
from like the Internet.
And there was a CIA handbook that you could download.
I don't know if it's real or not but one of the things that they told you how to
do in there is they said there's enough chemicals and a pack of cigarettes to
kill somebody and you boil it down you distill it and you can make like a paste
that you'd put on like a doorknob.
And then if somebody like touches it it'll kill them like you'll get them like
oh same cut same type of deal with the nicotine thing where it's an absorbent.
So toxic.
Easy.
That's so crazy.
It says here cigarette smoke contains 4000 chemicals including 43 known cancer
causing compounds and 400 other toxins.
Forty three out of four thousand is not that bad though if you you know only 43
of them cause cancer but there is five hundred and ninety nine ingredients.
So I don't know why there's five hundred nine nine ingredients and 4000
chemicals.
I don't know how that works but all those things were approved.
That's what's really crazy.
And they say I put that in yeah.
We're thinking about throwing formaldehyde and so I hope we're still golfing
right.
Yeah.
I mean this through all these different chemicals and what's really fascinating
about it is the object or the the the purpose of all these chemicals is just to
try to make you more addictive.
Right.
So it is just what the flavor comes from does it.
I don't know.
I don't think a cancer chemical.
I mean they're just they add a bunch of shit according least to that movie that
Russell Crowe movie.
Yeah just to try to get you more and more hooked you know
does a great job.
Yeah.
It's really addictive.
Imagine you came out with a product today that did the damage the cigarette did
and he tried to push it.
You know if you came out with some new thing.
Yeah.
And he killed.
I half a million people a year.
Like a vaporizer.
They get superhot and burns down on anybody man.
Not yet not mass produced.
Do you think they're dangerous.
No I was talking about though that one because it gets so high.
Yeah yeah.
They think I don't know.
I mean it takes a long time to find the stuff out doesn't it don't have to do
like 20 year studies and things like before they kind of really know.
I mean as far as you know I read about it because I do it all I use a vaporizer
so I like you worry.
Yeah a little bit like I look up whenever I see anything about it it seems like
they find that it's not it's it's not as good as not doing anything but it's a
little better than smoking.
It's not as good for you as not doing it but it's not as bad for you as smoking
cigarettes.
Yeah.
So for people that smoke cigarettes you got a kind of way your options like do
you think you're gonna be able to quit.
And if you can you just quit on your own.
Right.
But if you don't think you be able to quit you kind of do that and get your fix.
Yeah this is good.
No it's not good.
But like I've been doing it for like seven years now and now I don't even like
when I want nicotine.
I don't think about a cigarette like you think about that.
Yeah.
So I was like some smoked a cigarette an hour ago now and I probably actually
smoked one probably a month ago but like one had like a party one.
Yeah you could do that.
Yeah.
Because I just I just this I mean I smoke one cigarette maybe three or four
times a year.
Like really infrequently now Stephen King gives himself one cigarette when he
finishes a book.
Oh I know.
That's why I read so many books.
It's his whole motivation.
But isn't that interesting.
Like he'll he allows himself a cigarette when he finishes a book huh.
Uh
get the hell up your productivity.
There's a documentary that I'm in called the culture the culture high.
Recent documentary by the same people that did this other documentaries and
called the union and it's all about how the prison industry and the medical
marijuana on marijuana has been demonized.
How many people are in jail because of it.
Just the percentage of people that are non-violent drug offenders that are in
there because of marijuana.
And how many how many people like the literally drug war would dissolve if it
wasn't for marijuana being illegal.
Right.
The amount of people who get arrested for other drugs pales in comparison.
But one of things they talked about was cigarettes and they said that if you
take if you smoke two packs of cigarettes.
That's the that's the breaking number where you are 4000 times more likely to
get cancer to two packs of cigarettes.
Yeah in your life.
No no no no.
Every day every day two packs a day 4000 times more.
I might have made those numbers out by the way they sound good.
I listened to it on a point man watching a plane half awake.
That's crazy that's a lot of cigarettes.
Two packs a day not for dogs and hope that means he throws them down.
John Mellencamp does for.
Does he really.
I heard that.
I read it sounded like one of his show about him.
He smokes like four.
But within the air you see him an interview.
He's smoking and then he's like lighting the other one.
Like when that one's going out like he's just going back to back things all day.
I was in Indiana and at a UFC and John Mellencamp was in the audience and they
showed a picture of him.
You know they showed the video of him in the crowd and showed it to the audience
and they booed him really
liberal.
They think he's.
And I had to ask her why don't they like John Mellencamp.
He's from Indiana.
I was born in a small town.
Yeah.
Whole deal.
Nope.
He's a liberal.
He must have said something.
There must be something.
I wonder if you got outspoken on some sort of issue that like slavery so that
you know even like that.
Yeah.
I don't know what it was man but they booed the shit out of him it seems like
it's crazy.
Jack and Diane.
Yeah.
He likes
he's too liberal for Indiana.
At least that crowd UFC crowd in Indiana.
They were mad at him.
I couldn't believe it.
I was like goddamn John Mellencamp fucks commies.
I wonder if he had any idea of that before he went that's got to suck go to see
like a UFC fight and an entire lake place hates you.
It was a large number of people booing him too.
It wasn't just like a couple of boos scattered in the clapping and applause
Yeah.
That's kind of you tell your wife like you know I think I need to see the rest
the fight let's just get in the car pretend we're in the bathroom.
Fire up cars you're either falling winches and this.
There's certain spots in the country you're not allowed to be liberal.
You mean you really are not you're allowed to be kind of conservative anywhere
you'll be mocked but it's not dangerous per say but if you're a liberal in
certain parts of the country like you are that that's that team mentality.
Yeah.
Are you a Raiders fan.
You know there's like you know I mean it's like that team mentality really comes
out.
People love to defend their team.
And when you are a liberal you're thought to be weak.
You god damn bleeding heart.
Oh yeah.
You're gonna help all those welfare moms and all although you know they just
take that money and spend it on fucking drugs you know Joe.
The like I we had all these conspiracy sites like you know a lot of them you
know get you know a lot of lean right.
You know like conspiracy sites and all of them right.
Yeah most of them.
And.
And remember when Texas was talking about seceding or Rick Perry was talking
about seceding from the union.
Yeah that's the layer when he was about to run for president.
Which is weird.
But he was like he's like you know we can secede.
And so like everybody on the conspiracy boards that were from Texas there's this
big thread everybody's talking about it and they're like and everybody was like
the first thing we're gonna do is we're gonna go to Austin and just kick
everybody's ass.
They said Yeah it's like we secede.
We're gonna get off and
this broken stop work and I burned it all up.
That's hilarious.
I've got to put more juice out there.
How much you got your earned dude.
A lot.
That's gross.
Yeah.
Doesn't isn't Texas like it's a different sort of a state.
It's like it's the way they're set up.
It's the Republic of touch.
Yeah yeah.
Because they
have my histories right.
I think during or leading up to the Civil War Texas wanted to be part of the
Union or it came that Texas could be part of the Union but then they wouldn't
accept them because they thought they didn't want to swing the amount of pro
slave states.
They didn't want to add another pro slave state and like kind of they had like a
equal you know amount of pro slave and non slave states.
So they didn't accept Texas is entrance into the union.
So they made their own country.
And then after the Civil War when they asked Texas to come into the country they
had this kind of
caveat you know which should they're like OK but at any point if we want to
leave we can leave.
If it gets shitty Oh it's a prenup.
Yeah.
Basically Texas is like the only state that came into the country with a prenup
and where they're like OK.
But we can leave at any time and so I think that's what rich Rick Perry was
talking about.
Is this the thing I got to unscrew
this is so goofy.
There's so much involved in these fucking things.
I can't believe you can only suck on it like four or five times and it runs out
of juice while you sat there cooking it for about 10 minutes probably not.
It wasn't that long the first time I called it it was gone for a minute.
Yeah but is it does that cooking the stuff.
How come it doesn't come out then.
It wasn't very little.
Yeah.
All right so where does it go.
You put it on that.
Yeah.
That coil.
This can only good for you and you gotta make that call.
This is my first and last day.
Oh yeah I made it because you had to build your own coils on these things.
What the fuck.
I have a bunch of wire in my car.
What's wrong with you.
I just love Nick really because it's the greatest drug pour it in.
See in this area ladies and gentlemen is what you do.
Just a little bit it.
This isn't even give me a buzz though.
I'd rather have a cigar.
You'll see that there's a video.
Oh fuck.
Watch out.
You're not attack really.
No video of this guy hand rolling a Cuban cigar with a GoPro on his head.
It's pretty dope.
You get to see how they do it.
So it's so much skill involved in that.
Are those legal here now.
Yes that's going to have a few though.
Would they sell them can you buy them in Los Angeles.
Good question but I think you're allowed to have a few now because we're kind of
opening up a thing.
Jamie finding out.
There's a number that you're allowed to have.
I'm pretty sure I'd imagine you could buy him now.
There's a lot of counterfeit ones.
And apparently there's so much of a demand for Cuban cigars that the quality has
diminished.
Really some of them.
Yeah.
It's they're just not worth as much as they used to be.
They're just not as good rather as they used to be because the soil's getting
depleted and there's a lot of fake ones a lot of counterfeit Cuban cigars.
But it's another one of those things just like the fucking rich guys that want
to go to Everest as you can bring in a hundred dollars worth of alcohol tobacco
from Cuba.
But do they sell them.
Do they sell them here in the States.
Yeah.
I just do it again.
I put this fucking stupid face up.
I might be retarded I need to go to a doctor.
Maybe that's what's happening.
This thing's making me stupid.
That's it.
I'll find out.
Yeah.
No no no.
That's what happened to everybody.
Well then why why Stephen King say it makes him smarter
well he's just saying it makes.
Oh you mean his brain work.
Maybe it makes him maybe makes you more creative but not smarter.
Well that's what Tony Hinchcliffe says Tony Hinchcliffe says when he smokes and
he writes it just way better.
I mean brains is firing up.
Well it's almost like you know all those.
Well I guess everybody smokes.
It's not really you know.
But like all those old writers you think about like Hemingway or he does all
smoking and drinking.
Well how about NASA when they were trying to do the moon landing ship.
They're all in the fucking control room.
They're all puffin.
It's kind of crazy.
Yeah they all had those weird like they're smoking in the spaceship.
There's no I don't know what it's there's like on the moon.
There's like so many cigarette butts up there.
They put the flag on them.
Buzz Aldrin.
Yeah.
The control room though in Houston when they were there were all like monitoring
it like they were all smoking is a bunch of guys smoking and they all looked
like Peter Parker's boss from Spider-Man.
I like those haircuts.
What's his name Jay Jonah Jameson.
Yeah that's.
That's what it looks like.
They're old school.
They all died in their 50s.
Cancer see.
Yeah that's it
got to a certain age just don't go wise old man.
It didn't make it.
Smoke cigarettes die.
A few hardy souls last deep in their 60s and they dark like days when they had
those remember those things you'd see people had those things on their neck so
they get down do you like that.
Yeah do they do that anymore.
Is that a good question.
There's a commercial that the air from some some woman she was beautiful when
she was younger and then she smoked a lot of cigarettes and got cancer and now
are half her face is missing and she's got no throat.
She wears a wig and and yeah she has like the whole I really hate those
commercials and gee whiz this thing on her neck.
I get the point of the commercials but they're so unpleasant.
Which is the point you know.
But there was a hack thing that comedians used to do I don't know who invented
it for us.
I think it was probably Hicks who first started putting the microphone he put a
microphone neck and started dialing like that and then Leary kind of ripped it
off from Hicks and a bunch of other people started ripping off from each other.
It became like well no one could tell you you can't do that.
And yeah it was the hack thing to do and you did a thing about smoking.
Yes stick the microphone on your neck to represent those things.
These have a thing they used to have to put.
Yeah it was
like you said a voice.
Yes it was just it was just something that vibrated right.
Did it did what your vocal cords would do.
Yeah or it.
Yeah.
Somehow or another picked up on the sounds you were trying to make with your
fucking cancer ridden neck and now would just be able to send it through our
mind.
That technology so that's the new and maybe mine would work better if you're
smoking can only worry about throat cancer anyway and I'm neither.
Fuck that thing.
Yeah.
That's an honor we're on our way to becoming aliens right.
Aliens have those little tiny mouths because they didn't need em anymore.
Yeah big giant stupid heads cause all they're doing is like sending data with
their heads and needles large hard drive up there.
Well we'll probably end up just being computers will upload us into like some
sort of hard drive cause.
Probably more complicated in that we're probably going to be some sort of
artificial creation like an artificial body not necessarily a computer but like
you know everything about us artificial not like living well you know eventually
probably a virtual thing.
Mm hmm.
Well I realized like why we saw hung up on bodies.
Yeah you know just like maybe they'll just be it'll probably be like a computer
that has versions of us just kind of out of.
It's good to know where you came from.
You know computers paying respect like let's keep you know a lot of them
virtually inside of us.
And then the computers will go out and explore the galaxy and kind of yeah you
know and we'll just be kind of an interesting footnote.
You know that they kind of pay respect to what the fuck.
Yeah.
We'll be like and you go to the zoo and you see those like fake cave people you
know.
Yeah.
Statues of the fake people by the cave Neanderthals.
Yeah I think this is where we came from.
You know they were kind of not as smart as we are and that's what we'll be to
the computers will have people.
These are these are early men.
They have people that are just bent over looking at their phone and that's this.
That's what they're like that's baby us.
That's them with baby us.
Yeah.
Instead of like having a club where those big cavemen Flintstones style clubs
with the fur on like.
Like you know 2001 A Space Odyssey look and people.
Yeah.
Instead of that they just have a dude with an iPhone like at a Starbucks
tweeting about how great the Jinx was and then they'll have Google Glasses.
This was the first step of Google Glass and then the ever seen the virtual
reality ski goggles.
Where do you see the whole world in front of you becomes a desktop.
You start manipulating things in front of.
Oh yeah.
And yeah it's like Minority Report gathering.
Yeah but it's it's all you're what you're wearing goggles and through these
goggles you could see like I could see you but I also could like pull up things
in front of you.
Augmented reality.
Yeah this is a con.
Yeah.
Augmented augmented reality and then Oculus Rift.
Yeah that's gonna be huge.
Let's skip that comes out like this year.
I don't know.
I mean there's versions of it now like Duncan.
Duncan Trussell has he has an older version but he just tried the newest version
and he called me up screaming and ranting and raving.
Yeah.
Apparently it's in for K so it's just insanely graphic.
Like glue like insanely high definition beautiful video and the way they film
it.
They put cameras all over your body like these little small cameras are
everywhere you're moving so that option is available so long as you move to the
right you could.
They've already got video of that you move to the left in the processing speed
of computers today is apparently good enough to keep up with this.
Yeah and your you go into a room and when you go into this room is a guy playing
the piano and he goes you really feel like you're in a room with the guy playing
the piano.
It's that good.
That's crazy.
Yeah I was reading something about this company that's that's trying to start up
where what they're gonna do is take these because I think it's like a it's like
a spherical camera that is basically recording in all directions at once.
They want to go to like Everest.
They want to go to the pyramids.
They want to plant one of these things and you pay like a monthly service and
then you're just sitting in your home you're like I want wanna see what it's
like at the pyramids right now.
And you put this on and you're there they're going to put one on a satellite in
low orbit I'm going around the planet so you can just be like floating in space
over like anywhere you want.
And then the they're saying that like what's really gonna be crazy about it is
how it's going to change news because like CNN will have their camera like you
know Fox News will have their camera.
So like you know something happens in Ferguson you know they go down there and
they plant their camera there and then you can just air all their viewers can
just go and actually be at like the where the news is happening and you can kind
of look around and see for yourself you can watch the State of the Union with
you know the camera there and you see what your specific state senator is doing
why you see John McCain playing poker on his phone doesn't going to war with
Syria.
Remember when that was going on he was advocating going to war with Syria and he
was playing fucking angry birds.
They caught him doing it to me and he's still working there.
I like that should be something you should be paying attention to Marin.
Maybe we should get somebody in there is paying attention not playing Pope on
their fucking phone dude.
Christ how trivial is war to you.
Yes it is less important than Farmville.
Oh I can't help but he can't help but it's like someone sitting there talking to
you at dinner.
They have to check their phone and the call of kings and queens and aces just
pulls him in.
How old is he.
A thousand.
Because people were like him when he was running for president people like he's
gonna die like yeah next year or two and that was eight years ago now.
Well he's unhealthy too.
I mean it's not like he's just old and he exercises a lot and now he's not Jack
Lil Wayne.
I mean he's he was really fucked up because of being a prisoner warm.
He was tortured and his shoulders are fucked up like really beyond repair.
That's the thing he can't raise his hands again like raise his arms over his
head and he's not like physically well but he makes sense sometimes just weird
you know he's not off about everything.
Like he starts talking like one of the things about when he and Obama were
debating he was they were talking about going into Afghanistan and you know
Obama was like you know we'll just go in and we'll send troops to take care of
the bad guys.
And McCain was like Whoa wait a minute man that's when we came made sense
because like this guy was in war.
You know like was a prisoner of fucking war was tortured held by the Vietcong
and he was like it is not that easy man like you.
Do you know what it's like over there.
One of the things that he said that really fucking stunned me and I had to
research and it turns out is totally true.
He said most of Afghanistan operates essentially exactly the way it did when
Alexander the Great was around
yeah he's like You're talking about a country that's never been conquered.
Yeah like you.
It's the terrain itself makes it just almost impenetrable.
Like you you're going to send troops into the mountains.
Yeah.
And it was like our plan to bankrupt the Russians was to get them involved over
there.
Yeah with the same people that were fighting.
So it's like we we like set this great trap and then walked like you know just
forgot about it.
It's like the kid from home alone went home one day and forgot all the stuff
that he had set for the burglars.
Well it's almost like they set a trap and then didn't realize that trap had
heroin in it.
Oh wait a minute.
This isn't a church.
We left other great hair.
Forget what I said.
Let's try one more time but do it right and grow heroin.
OK.
This is gonna cost us so much money.
Not really.
It's actually just minor to certain around.
I can move it.
Oh well the beautiful thing they found recently.
They said they found recently that there's trillions of dollars worth of
minerals in the mountains.
Yeah it's the stuff they use to make batteries.
Yeah.
To blow on this thing.
Now makes noise I mean the whole for a broken zip file and it's full.
You had to do it because you saw me do it.
Get it out.
You get that pole.
Monkey see monkey do.
It's exciting.
It's like Pavlov's dog.
Ring that bell
This is not going to be a regular thing.
Listen to this podcast he got.
He asked me if he could do his and I said All right.
Yeah.
Do it man.
And then I'm fucking doing it to have bottles of this shit.
What if I drank that.
How quick would I die Piper.
I think I think within Yeah like the whole bottle.
Mm hmm.
Ten dollars says that you die with.
If you put that into someone's drink I.
You know people were talking about porn roofies in someone's drink what do you
pour this into like someone had like a younger bomb.
Yeah you just have a heart attack.
You just probably have a heart attack within a couple hours.
Yeah.
Right.
The stimulant.
It's crazy this guy sent me fucking heart attack juice.
I got it my fingers.
Is that bad.
I don't think I don't think we do.
Dude you had gloves on.
Yeah.
That was back in 2007.
I'm sure they've changed the formula.
I'm sure this is random guy this guy's going to even know what his face looks
like.
How dare I miss the whole thing is ridiculous man.
What's the next thing you know.
Well they vaporized alcohol now.
Have you seen that.
Yeah you look it up on YouTube it's crazy.
Yeah.
It's this it's like this little kit you can buy and you like heat it up and you
put like alcohol on it and then people just taken these vapor hits of alcohol
that's quick and then they just.
The FDA just legalized powdered alcohol this week.
So now you can like snort vodka.
What.
Yeah they approved it.
That can't be good.
It sounds but you know sounds worth trying.
Would you try it.
Oh yeah.
How would you know Mitch.
Just guess.
Like you know one of the good things about our cause it's super powerful.
But you kind of know what a shot of tequila is right.
Shot of tequila is pretty uniform.
Mm hmm.
You know that's why I like whiskey is okay.
But moonshine is illegal.
Well I guess I never thought about it but yeah you're right.
Cause there's some there's some sort of well isn't moonshine just illegal
because it's unregulated.
Yeah.
You know and they don't know how what the percentages are putting in there.
Like ever clear that stuff's legal right.
Yeah.
And then some states some states some states it's not yes states have weird laws
on booze like Utah has got weird laws on booze like your beer can't even be that
strong.
Yeah.
Because Mormons.
Fucking Mormons.
I was there recently and it was hilarious when we landed.
We're coming down the escalator and there was all these people that were waiting
there for the missionaries to return.
The elders were in like foreign countries convincing these poor people to sign
up and become Mormons and not drink caffeine.
It's so fucked up man.
So we're coming down the aisle.
Now you can drink caffeine.
I really can drink coffee.
It's a loophole you can't drink you can't drink coffee but you can drink
caffeine.
So my friend who was a Mormon used to drink Monster Energy drinks all day.
Oh and I was like wait a minute you're not allowed to drink coffee but you could
drink that.
He's like guys uncovered not covered by Jesus
Jesus doesn't say anything about fucking XYZ college he drinks he's cool with
taurine what is taurine bad for you.
Probably that's the shit that's in red bull right.
Just fucking dude I'm not telling.
I'm not lying.
He.
I never saw him was like he was.
His arm is connected to his can of fuckin monster energy drink and drink that
shit all day long.
Yeah.
You haven't got something.
If they if that's anything you can have and you're going to be addicted to it.
Well before he was a Mormon he was a he had some issues with some substances and
then his wife got him to convert over and then he just went with the program.
But he liked his caffeine.
So he came in Monster's energy drink kind of a guy but a lot of those dudes that
are like AA guys cigarettes and coffee.
Yeah they're not drug free by any goddamn stretch of the imagination.
They're just not taking anything that just a bullet or your consciousness right.
They're just altering it on a consistent basis.
Yeah.
For some it's a little easier on your liver.
Yeah it's definitely easy.
Well the cigarettes aren't cigarettes bad for your liver.
I don't know bad for everything.
Your whole body is like what do we do with the shits in your bloodstream.
Your pancreas apparently pancreatic cancer is a big one.
Cigarette smokers the lungs of course but this.
You know it's it's done so many different processes in your body.
There's so many different things that are just going what is all this shit.
People should just do nitrous all day every day.
That's how things do with this man.
There's something about doing whippet.
If you commit to like whip hits and huffing paint you're kind of in the same
category.
Like wait wait what are you doing.
I'm taking some stuff that you're not supposed to get high with and you're using
it to get high.
That's not cool.
But meanwhile whip it's the whip it's fuck you up more than a glass of Jack
Daniels whip its are amazing.
They're like I went through a phase I was done a lot of efforts and oh God.
And it was you know I mean you have had to stop because it was just like this is
I enjoy this but you just can't give you brain damage.
Well everything there's you're brain damaged doesn't it.
I mean you lose like two hundred or twenty thousand brain cells a day just from
you know waking up you know kind of walking around like so it's I mean I think
it's you know you have like a thousand and you get new ones.
No.
Yeah.
I don't get no one ever.
No.
Fuck.
I think it's I think you have what you have.
I think you get new ones if you do mushrooms and showing what that makes sense.
Probably really for real.
Yeah.
It's like one of the few things that I've been shown to like regenerate neurons
in the brain or something like that so just do as much mushrooms as you are
doing nitrous and you'll be fine.
Maybe you would probably have to live in a mountain somewhere and get so
detached from everybody's show yourself when you get firewood and go back to
your cabin.
I was I was doing a sketch like a music video for this country music song called
you knows about blue laws in states like you know and if they won't tell you
alcohol you know that the song is called What About mouthwash and it is like you
know all these different things like what about mouthwash What about huffing
paint and all these things that you could you could do and for the music video
it was like oh fuck it we'll just you know we're in the truck got some paint and
spray paint in a bag.
And my friend had like mouthwash and so we're just like did it for the shot.
And I I just you know cause the shot was on so I just sprayed the spray paint in
the bag and then I just huffed in and it's so fast it's so immediate and it's so
high.
Do to you it's like we did it and I was like and then I kind of broke take.
I was like whoa like you know like this really works like huffing paint is like
the real deal.
Oh that's so funny.
It's quick.
That's so funny.
Oh have you ever talked to someone who works in an auto body shop like spray
painting cars.
No.
You know they wear those masks and shit but it doesn't really work.
I mean it works a little bit but if you're spray painting a car you go into
those boots.
Those guys get high as far back as like the hidden secret of auto body work.
It's such a dirty high kill.
I'd imagine the paint high this huffing it doesn't feel like like it's good for
you
like you're drinking kills Yeah you're like lightheaded and you're like well I'm
high and you're like this is gonna feel bad when it wears off.
Oh God that's so crazy.
Wow.
Do you everybody seen those images of the guy who got arrested several times he
has paint a fucking goatee of silver paint over his face like fuck man it's so
weird.
You ever see that.
I forget what show it was.
It's one of those if there's a rehab show or something.
Interventions show.
Yeah.
Where the gross is addicted a duster the dust stuff these brand you see on your
keyboard that area.
What does that do to you.
I guess it gets you high.
And I've never done it but like she was going through like she just would
forward a Wal-Mart and she'd go to Wal-Mart to fill up her cart with duster and
she does this every day just because someone just does dusty all day.
You know the problem with that show is I have been I've been exposed too much to
how television works.
And I just as parliaments can bullshit.
Part of me saying like you this person is so together that they've contacted the
producers of this show they're on the show they're walking around the cameras
following them.
Really.
Sure.
Are you sure they're not engineering this whole thing but do they call or do
their families call.
That's a good question.
I just don't get why.
I mean like if I had a loved one who was like you know like I had a problem you
know I was like I gotta do an intervention like the last thing I ever think of
it is like I gotta get a TV show to watch this thing like you know you say that
but I mean what the fuck did Dr. Drew do for all those years.
He's doing Celebrity Rehab.
He took these people at their most vulnerable time and publicly shamed them
showed them on television having the DVD freaking out each other.
Screaming at each other incredibly vulnerable and expose them to the world for
other people's amusement.
And he's a doctor.
Yeah addiction specialist so only has I gotten dry when TV is involved in
profits involved people have weird ways of rationalizing things.
This is the only way these people will get help but you do it on TV.
No.
But I mean like the family.
I mean do you think the family do they.
I guess they have to get paid something to do it.
They have to get paid something.
Yeah.
And it's not like a windfall.
The family might be morons you know they might not think it's the way to do it.
It's very.
I mean there there is a show that I was obsessed with for a long time cause I
didn't know I was pregnant.
Have you seen that show.
Have you seen it.
It's fucking amazing.
Find it on like iTunes or whatever but it's it's a show where they would.
It's about people who just didn't realize that they were pregnant then they have
their babies in the toilet or you know just walking to work or something and
they would reenact it like it was kind of like Unsolved Mysteries style where
they'd interview the real people and then they'd have actors like playing it out
like oh my stomach hurts.
I mean go take a shit and then the baby they put they throw the crazy thing
about the show is that I watched one episode where they had the mom get up you
know and then the camera goes in the toilet and they put a real baby in a toilet
like a real like for the shot fuck you in the water.
Yeah they put a baby in that toilet bowl for the shot.
I like Mike didn't have a day Bronner is at an angle you can see I'm just
holding onto a seat on the block mom but that I knew a girl who worked on the
show and I was my finish she worked on and I was like How do you why do people
you know agree to do because they all look like idiots there's no way you can be
on that show and not look like one of the dumbest people on you know if you
didn't know you were pregnant like I was like why did they agree to let you do
this episode about him she was like we are getting calls all day from people
wanting to be on the show like we have to you know we're batting them off
because it's people seeing the idea of somebody playing them on television is so
enticing to people that the fact that someone is going to reenact their life is
like worth it yeah I'll be it I'll look like an idiot on television that's so
crazy though that's the poll having someone play you Wow that's amazing there
was a girl that worked at the bank that I used to go to when I was a kid and she
had her baby and threw it in the garbage and went back to work.
She worked at a bank.
No one knew she was pregnant.
She was overweight went to the bathroom had the baby threw in the garbage and
went back to work and then they figured out what the fuck happened in the
wrestler.
That's crazy.
Oh so crazy it was like I'd seen her I.
Person to Person approach shook hands with her.
I mean I don't remember like on the day 17.
No not on the day I think.
I think I found out about it like you know after the fact.
But it was like the talk of the town.
Yeah.
Like that.
I don't remember her name but you know I was like I think I was price 60 years.
I was working at Newport Creamery which was a ice cream and hamburger joint in
Newton Massachusetts.
So as probably I think I got that job when I was 16.
So it's probably when I was 16.
All this happened but it was just the whole town was talking about I was like
What.
She had a baby.
She was pregnant.
What.
That she put in the garbage like it was crazy.
Went to jail.
Yeah.
Whole thing was it really creep people it's creeps you out.
When you find out that insanity like that.
Was there the whole time and you were interacting with insanity like hello and
sane person Hi crazy you're about to have a baby and throw in the trash.
Yeah yeah.
You know like if you talk to her the week before you throw your baby in the
trash what's going to happen.
Who are you.
How do you know she might not have even known she was pregnant.
She might have been one of those people.
Oh a lot of the people who.
Most of the people in the show who did other pregnant are overweight.
Of course.
Yeah.
Yeah just.
They must be in such discomfort all the time.
Yeah.
Oh fuck man.
I don't understand.
Can't.
Yeah.
Kenya.
There's like there's certain levels of madness.
It's like there's a scale you know like you could be like a little crazy when I
got this thing.
I have to wear a different color socks.
You know I have this thing.
You know I only wear my underwear backwards.
You know how this thing I like to be a mascot.
I like to fuck other mascots and we get together.
I guess you could always get further and further down the crazy hole.
I have this thing.
I don't think I'm pregnant but if I ever am I'm definitely not going dumpster.
Well there was a bumper sticker once I saw a car like a cop car that was like
telling people they didn't have to throw their baby away and they could bring
their baby to a fire department.
Yeah the baby off or a police station like women went.
Who the fuck is like I'm on my way to the dumpster with my bike.
Oh look at that bumper sticker.
Oh I could just go to Fire Department.
I have options like you that you like what a great what a great service the
public is offering.
I've seen fire department things with a baby drop like like window.
I mean it's not like a like a block after you know but I mean it's like you know
it just says I've seen the sign that says like this is where you can leave an
unwanted baby so it must happen frequently enough that it's an regular thing
that like people are like you know that you know okay.
Fire departments are places that we can we can do OK.
And that's I just it's more evidence that we are there's groups of people when
you get to like when you have a city you know you have a million people or 5
million people or 10 million people whatever it is that when you get groups of
people that aren't really interacting with their neighbors they don't really
have real communities.
They don't they're not in real tribes.
They just sort of independent and wandering around is like madness all around
us.
Then which just like unrecognized unchecked madness ignored madness you know.
Yes all around us we just don't you know you don't have you don't deal with it
like if we there's only 50 of us we lived in the jungle together you know that
bitch is pregnant down Yeah you know Yeah well she wouldn't be fat she would
have to like gather food and everybody thin it's a wall it's a law how to drop
off an unwanted baby with easy pictures why now.
Safe Haven law you must drop them off at a police department fire station or any
hospital.
If a parent were to change their mind they have 30 days after dropping off their
infant to get their baby back from the state in 30 days.
Makes me so sad.
That's crazy imagine.
On the twenty ninth day the 24th hour he's come in I just want to be back.
Sorry you just missed the cut off.
Yeah it just it's 30 days right now.
Tick tock tick.
I got baby.
Give the baby back.
After one day like you know if if if you went through the idea if you like.
You know what maybe I'm going to drop this baby off at the fire department.
So you probably should drop the baby off at the fire so depressing it's so
depressing.
Imagine being that poor fucking kid and you find out that your mom dropped you
over the fire department possibly better.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Who knows.
But then the fucked up thing is that all the babies have to become firefighters.
It's part of a show about this where firefighters come from.
They've all been dry.
I think they come from store.
I could be wrong.
I think all firefighters have dropped off babies that grow up.
Fuck and you have to live in the firehouse.
Yeah.
Where's my toys.
I want an axe.
You got the coal pole.
You got the Dalmatian.
That's pretty good.
It's great if your stripper early training.
Fuck.
God damn what a weird world we live in now.
Just too many of us.
That's that's the only or too many of us.
I shouldn't see too many of us because the cool thing about cities.
The cool thing about large urban centers is you get a high concentration of
intelligence to high concentration of cool people high concentration of like
things happening and things moving and progress but there's too many of us that
aren't in contact with each other.
Yeah well it's weird.
Didn't like the population of the entire world stays somewhere around 1 billion
for as long as we can like kind of for a long time.
Like you know hundreds hundreds hundreds maybe thousands of years.
And then like once we invented basic at once we figured out how to use fossil
fuels and like plastics and things very kind of it shot up to like 7 billion
within like 100 years.
Like you have more of a chance.
I mean there's more people now and there's ever been by like a huge long shot
huge
yeah.
There was a thing there was less energy though day David was talking about the
population of the United States during World War 2.
And it was night in the 1940s.
It was one hundred and fifty million people or less.
Yeah.
Now it's more than 300.
It's like 350.
Is it 350.
That's fucking crazy.
And then then the world population is much larger than that.
The world population was at the time I think only like 2 billion and now it's at
7.
Yeah.
Which is stunning.
Yeah astronomical increase in human being.
What was that like 1 billion around like nineteen hundred or something.
So that's like your whole world.
Yeah.
And so it's like doubled it doubled in like 40 years and now it's it's crazy.
Yeah a lot of people.
And that's what makes you wonder.
That's it but that's the other thing about the points to urbanization and to
improvement of the quality of life is that apparently when the quality of life
improves and there's more resources people have less kids and then also when the
quality of life improves and resources improve.
The the people.
How does it go that people have less kids because their careers are become more
important and they become more more concerned with progress and with their
career than they do with having a family so they have families later and later.
That's one things they also tribute to the high the increase in autism.
I think there's a contributing factor.
Apparently like several times several fold is when you have children after a
certain age like it's many men right.
Men and women but it isn't.
Don't they think that it's linked to male sign that too that but women as well.
Women as they get older like birth defects increase in birth defect issues.
They didn't think it was men at all for a while but now they do.
I used to think it was just the age of the woman but now they think it's the age
of the man as well the age of the sperm that's gone through the roof.
To think something like one in twenty five now or something like autism.
Yeah I think they also think that that's also because they die.
Yeah they didn't really know what was wrong with Billy and now know they've
given it a name.
He's got autism or he's got he's on the spectrum he's you know he's got a
spectrum disorders I've got Asperger's.
Whatever dude.
What a great way to end this podcast.
Started out on AIDS ended up on after dropping off babies has been a hospital.
You're special dude.
It was this past Friday.
Yeah.
But it's available.
What's it called high end church.
Did you ever get Hydra.
Actually I would.
I went to like a Christian school and stuff so I was like I never actually got
high in church.
My friend has a story about something happening my friend that I wrote the song
about but like I've been hired like church basketball games and things like
that.
It's just it's it's not it's like you went to it you grew up Christian.
Yeah.
My parents were Christian rock singers in the 80s like Stryker striper now they
were like folk folk kind of folk and then it became rock kind of thing.
But I grew up on a tour bus traveling around the country.
Why.
Oh my God that's amazing.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
So you haven't really really conservative high school and you know.
Wow that's weird.
You break free.
Well I think it's it's when when something is around the land you know you're
kind of just you know as a kid growing up you're kind of just like OK.
Does everything have to be about you know church that kind of thing.
Like right.
So you just sort of you know so then like when I was in school it was always me
in like two or three of the other quote unquote bad kids that would be at the
back of the class just like not taking things seriously and kind of making fun
of everybody kind of thing.
So it was just odd.
There was this kind of like that.
You know Praise God praise God for people like you.
Yeah but that that often happens right.
I mean Cara Santa Maria is a friend of mine who say she's a beautiful
intelligent neuroscientist who grew up on a strict religious household.
She's a devout atheist and you know her parents don't like her.
Yeah.
Upset at her because she's an atheist and has metal in her face range.
But that's often times a case right.
Your parents are pushing a certain direction you rebound and go crazy.
Yeah I mean the other bag.
I mean the other kids that I would hang out with were like other pastor's kids
you know they're the kids in the back that weren't like taking things seriously.
Yeah they did get tired of their parents tell them what to do.
Yeah.
If you restrict your kids too much it's like what I'm saying about my daughter
the soccer shit like make them do anything man.
Ford make them do things you know you want your kid to not play piano.
Force them to play piano.
Fuck yeah right.
Yeah.
Sometimes it works.
But God.
The amount of resentment that children have for from really like overbearing
parents.
When I was a kid I did this girl that went to Catholic school and our parents
like super strict Catholics.
And she was the biggest hoe bag because of that because of that like that girl
probably fucked everyone who asked her.
Yeah.
Or everyone who wanted to take that Daddy.
But she's probably like 30.
She's went on a rampage like there was like a long list of people that I knew
that fucked her as crazy at a certain point time we were like.
By time we're like 19 or 20.
Like I dated her when I guess we were like 16.
And by the time we're like 19 20 I knew like a dozen dudes faster.
It's just chaos.
K was just fucking everybody.
And she was really pretty too.
So like everybody wanted to focus right.
It was just like she was just just all that suppression like her parents were so
overbearing so constantly drilling Jesus into her head and the Catholic guilt.
And she just couldn't wait to just finger herself and just start sucking Dad
run around and you know she would get so drunk that she would just throw up and
pass out.
She was out of fucking control and a lot of it was just her parents.
They just they just they just wound that spring up so tight
shot to the fucking moon.
It's weird how that works right.
Were your parents overbearing about it.
Not.
I mean it wasn't.
No it was I mean it was strict but it was like also not strict in weird ways
like you know like I couldn't watch most stuff on television.
Like what.
What was forbidden like Dukes of Hazzard.
No like like anything they had like more than one swear word.
Like I couldn't watch it.
So I watch The Simpsons and then they'd be like they'd say Damn something in the
back.
And my parents be like I want more and it's off and then be like oh god please
don't let Bart Simpson say Damn again.
No that to him was a swear word damn is a swear word.
And then I was allowed to watch R rated movies.
So and so still to this day like you know there's all these great movies that
you know came out and like the 90s that I just didn't really see stripes now
racing stripes.
But like I remember like a cut like when I was in my early 20s like my
girlfriend realized that I'd never seen any Terminators.
She's was like you haven't seen any Terminators.
McKnight never.
Never saw any of them like that and she's like you have to watch the Terminator
like that.
So we watched all three of them like that and binge Terminator I watched all
three turn.
She's like What do you think I was like.
I like the third one the best.
And she's like You're crazy.
She's.
But I didn't have the nostalgia play right.
So I just watched them all once I was like No I liked that they blew the world
up at the end.
I thought that was cool.
She's like No.
I was like the lady Terminator she was cool.
No no no no it's the second Terminator.
The second is the one that's what she was saying.
I thought the first was the one.
No the first one has a really shitty special effects.
Try to watch it today on Blu ray you'll go What the fuck is that.
What am I.
That's not Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Things mean a silly putty.
God so are your parents.
They're still around.
Yeah.
They still like super.
Jesus out.
Yeah.
They don't perform anymore but they're like you know they're my mom's a teacher
my dad's a graphic designer and failing.
Yeah but.
Yeah.
That's wild man.
So what do they think about.
Like you.
What you do.
They don't like it day to day.
You know my relationship is is fine with them.
You ever see you don't Trevor.
No but they would watch Trevor.
Yeah.
Well yeah I mean they though they don't like the material or the things that I
talk about or like what my you know comedy is usually about.
But you know I'm the same on the same.
On the other side of that coin.
They're happy that you know things are going well.
You know they're happy that you know that.
It's like a weird you know we kind of try not to talk about right stuff.
Like when the special came out I was like You know I waited until pretty much
the end.
Tom I guess called high end church
and they were going out there and they were talking about they're like Oh we're
excited for your special you know we're gonna go over and meet with some of our
friends and we're gonna watch it when it comes out and they're like they're like
Is it something we should watch him like now you know it's like it's like
there's like one song you can probably watch I'll send you all the high end
shirts.
Oh that's funny.
Oh my God.
Did they ever have a sit down with you like an intervention.
No no no.
I mean it was more of like just phone arguments kind of.
I did a song about the pope called the pope rap and that like.
And I knew I was about to come out.
It was from my last album.
And so I went home for Christmas one year and I'd already shot the music video
for it and I was like well I might as well just like you know what I'll do I'll
just kind of I'll just kind of nip this in the bud like I'll kind of show this
to him while I'm here I can answer any questions about it like you know.
So it's not like this it was a bad idea.
It's like ruined Christmas is a big fight.
And so now I just I've learned from that I'm like just just don't watch it.
What was there are you when they say to you.
Well it's just like you know why would you Oh you don't even know what it is
it's like I think a lot of it like they think that it's a personal or they used
to think that it was a personal affront to them.
And it's not you know like like you were rebelling against mom specifically or
mocking because because they were Christian musicians that it is that it's and I
could see them thinking that but it's like what I kind of had to explain is like
you know what I a lot of my comedy comes is about religion history and politics.
But that's because that's where I grew up I grew up on like a civil war
battlefield in Virginia like I'd go out with my grandfather and we would like
you know find cannonballs with metal detectors and like you would dig them up
and stuff like Hey yeah it's just history was everywhere.
My my uncles were Civil War reenactments you know like yeah it was like a big
history was that the big thing.
What inside were they reenacting Bolzano they were confederates it's
so.
Gone Yeah what they did.
Ali what did they do they just put the outfits on and shareholders be hundreds
of people you would be like you know they reenact whole battles like now when
you say reenact they use like muskets with no balls you just flash powder and
they all walked across the field walking Hilaire and then all the women come and
they dress up at the time they kind of cheer everybody on and it's like wow yeah
my god that must be awesome yeah well see I was born in New York and I came down
in all of my family lived in Virginia and so like everyone like when I read all
that when I was a kid everybody would play civil war and like all of my cousins
had like civil war outfits and I had and I was the only Yankee so I get my ass
kicked all the time and I was always like you know that's not how it happened.
This is not a war really panned out like you know the areas you'd have to give
you.
So they wanted the South to win all the wars.
Oh well I mean I think did they ever allow like the South to lose because you're
reenacting the war.
Well no no.
In the reenactments are one thing I'm talking about when both planes make my
cousins like that.
No no no they they did it authentically to like how the battles would actually
play out.
So see it's very organized like it's people just running around and you're
shooting and then I guess when you run out you like fake death or die and then
you kind of lay on the ground for the rest of the battle.
What is the fucking motivation to do that.
I don't know how any other day don't reenact World War 2.
They don't know one storms the beach of Normandy again.
Well we have both sides here and all their battle all the battlefields are here.
Oh OK.
So he's on.
You know we can.
Yeah you could do it.
You can go to Gettysburg.
It's a couple hour drive from us people.
You know my step dad when he said it was really depressing.
He said I've never felt sadness in a location before.
He said his back.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I was there he goes you could feel it you like you feel the fact that all those
people died there.
If that makes any sense at all.
Now is the dark place.
And he's not a woo woo guy is pretty straightforward guy.
So when he told me that I was like Wow.
Really.
Yeah.
You could feel it.
I'll bet Normandy is like that.
You go there.
I bet there's a heavy Paul you know.
I'd imagine there was somebody who did something on Normandy where they did they
made like like sand images of all of the bodies like the thousand that represent
the thousands of people that died on that beach.
And it was really creepy because you looked him is it me.
It was I think it's important for people to understand the actual loss of life
that you're dealing with.
Yeah but when this guy did it it was like an artist.
There it is.
Well that's some.
And those things that are there are those things from the war that are still
there.
Is that what that is.
Those those black things yeah.
Is that what those are.
I think they are.
I think that's what that is.
But I don't claim I'm that wrong.
They're never gonna clean it up.
But look at what that represents.
That's crazy.
Imagine being there and seeing all those fuckin bodies in real time.
I mean these people were showing up in boats and as they're getting out of the
boats are just getting shot at.
Pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop pop.
Yeah.
I mean it's like that.
That's the mindblowing thing about America's big battles and wars.
I mean you go to basic training you spend all this time like preparing and then
you get dropped into something like that.
I mean how much of it is I mean it's I guess so I guess that's why you hear all
those whenever you you know hear an interview it's like a war veteran and
they're like You know I'm not a hero.
The real heroes are the people that you know die that day.
I mean it's just like it's just luck you know you're just like one of the people
that got through and like you know I mean it's just not that opening scene in
Saving Private Ryan saving Private Ryan.
Yeah opening scene when everyone's getting blown up in front of him and tennis
shoes is fucking right.
That's real man.
That's that's the real war.
You know that was one of the things about that Brian Williams thing that I found
particularly disturbing when Brian Williams got caught not telling the truth
about his helicopter getting shot at.
What was interesting to me was not just that this fucking news guy lied but that
the pilot of the helicopter he was on was telling his version the story because
they had interviewed him and he said well our power our helicopter did get hit
with small arms fire and the helicopter in front of us was the one that got hit
by the RPG and then we had to land and we had to drop off our our load first.
And that's why we were an hour behind them.
But we were all in the same convoy.
So he's telling the stories is essentially like letting Brian Williams off the
hook a little bit because you're saying like when we did get hit you know we got
hit we know we're being attacked there's no doubt about it.
And then a lot of people were like well why would he lie about that.
Because the lie doesn't make him look any better like you were you were in a war
you were getting attacked you did have to land.
You did take small arms fire and you were stuck in a sandstorm for two for two
days so that that all line story.
It's a fucking crazy story just a sandstorm just a being just watching another
helicopter in front of you get hit with an RPG.
But then the guy said that he got calls from all these other people that were
saying No you didn't have Brian Williams in your helicopter.
This guy did or that guy did.
And it was like more than one story emerging of different people saying that
they had Brian Williams in his helicopter and then he said you know what.
I don't even want to I don't.
I might be wrong.
I don't even want to talk about this anymore because because I've been doing
these interviews about this now all the nightmares are coming back.
It's like I tried to put this aside and it put in my mind.
It made me really think about getting over traumatic situations like that and
how much how much of the truth of that you know we're talking about like 12 plus
years ago.
How much of the truth do you retain in your memory and how much of it is just
really really confusing and fucked up because it is just bullets and chaos and
nightmares and dead bodies and who knows how many times that guy saw somebody
die and then they're asking him to recall a very specific instance where it's
one very specific unremarkable at the time news guy was with them.
Yeah unremarkable at the time because nothing happened other than yes news guy
was there he probably took a bunch of different people.
Yeah.
Who knows.
I mean he's not excited that Brian Williams is in a helicopter.
Yeah I'm here.
The crazy thing is he's in war and he's getting shot at.
He's got these all PTSD out.
And so you know he said you know respectfully I just don't want to talk about
this anymore just because of my memories like it's really fucking me up and all
these things that I tried to forget.
Now I'm being forced to remember them again and my memory might be fucked up.
As I wow that is that's something to consider that memories are not carved in
stone.
They're just not they cheer.
I mean there's there they're there.
They're almost hardly used in courts you know eyewitness stuff like because it's
like it's you change you know embellishment.
Mm hmm.
Like you know you always tell me I always like you know tell a story and then
somebody you know from like 10 years ago and so maybe like that's not what
happened it happened like this.
And then you're like oh yeah you're right it did.
It's just kind of it's changed.
And you see it a certain way like it can just like small things but you're like
oh I guess that was this person in my mind I remember it being this other person
that was there but I guess you guess that person wasn't there like you know and
then you have to go well.
Are you sure you got it right.
Right.
It's like oh yeah I remember some things very clearly very clearly because I
kind of told the story more than once and the points in the story that were
specific were very important.
Well yeah there's some other stories that are just fucking loosely pieced
together flashes in my brain.
Yeah the images that I can kind of recall kinda and chain of events that can
kind of recall correctly.
Yeah but people are just some people are married to the idea that they remember
everything exactly how it happened.
Nobody does.
I don't think it's it's the weird thing is like when you tell a story or like
something say something crazy happens in college and it's a story right out the
gate you know kind of thing and you're telling that story and you tell it story
for years and years and years and then a certain point you really remember the
actual event anymore but you remember the story you've been telling the story
forever like like you said it's going to be I remember when this happened you're
like now but I do remember the story you know.
I remember it happened but I have no memory of it anymore really.
And then some people remember shit you don't remember at all.
And then like come on man no remember we did that thing together.
Like I don't even know what the fuck you're talking about is this guy crazy or
do I just not have a memory of an actual event.
Yeah which one is this.
Tell you what I mean to remember forever more this podcast.
Me too.
Smoking is good for your memory.
Yes nicotine.
I think we're out of time.
We're gonna turn into a pumpkin any minute now.
Who am I Trevor Moore.
I the letter I.
Trevor Moore on Twitter website.
Trevor Moore dot org high in church.
You get it on Comedy Central direct as well as five buck jammies.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh nice.
Is that Louis C.K.
set the fucking model.
Yeah.
And we all that's it dude.
Thank you very much.
Let's do this again.
Thanks for having me on.
This was a blast.
Again we will do it again.
All right and again awesome.
And then we'll have false memories about the podcast we did.
All right my friends.
See you soon.
Much love.